[Musique]
la séance est ouverte le compte rendu
intégrale de la séance du jeudi 6
juillet était publiée sur le site
internet du Sénat il n'y a pas
d'observation le procès-verbal est à
adopté j'informe le Sénat que son
parvenu à l'adoption d'un texte commun
les commissions mixte paritaires
chargées d'élaborer un texte sur la
disposition restant en discussion d'une
part sur le projet de loi relatif à la
restitution des biens culturels ayant
fait l'objet de spoliation dans le
contexte des persécutions antisémites
permettraient entre 1933 et 1945 d'autre
part sur la proposition de loi visant
renforcée l'accompagnement des élus
locaux dans la mise en œuvre de la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi pour le plein emploi la
procédure accélérée était engagée sur ce
texte et dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du shop
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur monsieur le ministre cher
Jean-Christophe mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs le débat que nous ouvrons
aujourd'hui sur ce projet de loi pour le
plein emploi nous donne je crois la
possibilité de mettre à profit les
quelques heures ou quelques jours de
débats que nous avons devant nous pour
tordre le coup à trois idées reçues la
première idée auquel il faut qu'entendre
le coup et le fait que contre le chômage
nous n'avons pas tout essayé et nous
pouvons encore développer mobiliser de
nouvelles politiques d'accompagnement et
de retour à l'emploi la deuxième idée
que je vous propose là aussi d'étendre
c'est celle qui voudrait que le chômage
de masse soit une fatalité pour notre
pays alors que nous le voyons depuis
maintenant quelques années le chômage
baisse peut continuer à baisser
l'objectif de pleine d'emploi est
atteignable et enfin c'est cette
troisième idée laquelle je veux tordre
le coup le fait que le paiement en
France serait une utopie alors que tout
aujourd'hui démontre comme cet objectif
peut être atteint
que nous mettons en place les bonnes
politiques en matière de développement
économique et d'emplois je suis donc
très heureux de vous présenter ce projet
de loi pour le Pôle Emploi un projet de
loi qui veut faire la preuve que
personne n'est qui que personne n'est in
employable que tous les demandeurs
d'emploi doivent être accompagnés que
les personnes en situation de handicap à
la recherche d'un emploi sont avant tout
des personnes qui cherchent un emploi et
que nous devons accompagner en
conséquence c'est aussi un projet de loi
qui permettra au marché du travail
d'inclure ceux qui en sont le plus
éloignés aujourd'hui cela même qui
pendant des décennies ont été reléguées
au second rond par la qualité la
fatalité du chômage de masse et enfin
c'est un projet de loi qui fidèle à
l'ambition fondamentale de la majorité
présidentielle depuis six ans souhaite
lutter contre les assignations à
résidence permettent des mobilités
professionnelles et s'inscrire dans des
logiques de parcours et d'émancipation
vous le savez ce texte complète la série
de réformes naît depuis 2017 pour
libérer le potentiel de croissance et
d'emploi dans le pays nous avons d'ores
et déjà voulu faciliter l'accès des
jeunes à l'emploi avec la réforme de
l'apprentissage avec le contrat
d'engagement jeune ou encore avec
l'engagement de la réforme du lycée
professionnel nous avons voulu aussi
mettre en place des règles plus
incitatives pour le retour à l'emploi et
c'est l'objet de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui a été promulguée
au mois de décembre dernier nous voulons
continuer d'augmenter l'emploi des
seniors et le nombre de personnes en
emploi c'est aussi une des raisons qui
nous a amené à conduire la réforme des
retraites il a quelques semaines ces
réformes nous ont rapprochées puisque
jamais du plein emploi et en effet qui
aurait pu imaginer il y a quelques
années encore que nous serions
aujourd'hui avec le taux de chômage le
plus faible que notre pays est connu
depuis 40 ans et le taux d'emploi le
plus fort depuis qu'on le mesure en 1975
en effet ce taux d'emploi a atteint
68,6% c'est un record depuis la création
d'indicateurs et il se traduit par
ailleurs par une augmentation très
significative du taux d'emploi des
jeunes comme du taux d'emploi des
seniors cela s'explique à la fois par le
retour à l'emploi de beaucoup d'entre
eux ça s'explique par les politiques
d'accompagnement cela s'explique aussi
par les politiques d'inclusion qui nous
ont permis par exemple et j'y reviendrai
que le taux de chômage des personnes en
situation de handicap soit passé de 15 à
12% en l'espace d'un an bref j'ai une
mère ces idées génères ces points pour
souligner que nous sommes plus proches
que jamais de cet objectif qui est
d'attendre les 5% de chômage à l'échelle
du pays
il nous a fallu beaucoup de travail
beaucoup d'efforts je crois pour sortir
d'une forme de déni collectif et
d'innaction de manque de détermination
aussi qui a pu conduire à se satisfaire
d'une situation de chômage de masse
aussi durable les résultats qui sont
déjà atteints ou réjouissent mais ils
nous posent aussi des questions
et ces résultats nous obligent et nous
obligent aussi à vouloir aller plus loin
je le disais il y a un instant le
paiement est désormais un objectif
atteignable puisque jamais il nous faut
créer un peu plus de 700 000 nouveaux
emplois pour y parvenir alors que nous
avons d'ores et déjà créé l'économie
française à d'ores et déjà créé un
million 700 000 emplois mais en réalité
nous devons faire face à d'autres enjeux
et à d'autres challenges le défi n'est
plus seulement de faire baisser les
chiffres du chômage de remettre en
emploi ceux qui en étaient très proches
mais bien de tenir deux objectifs
complémentaires et qui prennent une
acuité nouvelle notre premier ambition
c'est de permettre aux personnes les
plus fragiles qui sont hors de l'emploi
depuis longtemps de trouver ou de
retrouver un emploi et de bien souligner
dire que la pleine emploi séparaissence
le plein d'emplois pour tous et partout
la seconde ambition que je vous propose
de partager c'est de faire en sorte que
les entreprises ne payent plus à
recruter alors que même que notre pays
compte encore autant de personnes au
chômage de personnes qui cherchent
activement un emploi vous le mesurez
tous dans vos départements les
entreprises ne manquent pas d'activité
mais de main d'oeuvre et donc nous
devons apporter une réponse à ces
difficultés de recrutement nous devons
aller plus loin que les mesures qui ont
été mises en œuvre pour réduire ces
difficultés ces tensions de recrutement
et cela passe évidemment par la
rénovation du service public de l'emploi
c'est là tout le projet de France
travail ce projet part d'un constat
assez simple notre pays a un problème
d'efficacité de son service public de
l'emploi et ça n'est pas lié à
l'investissement de celles et ceux qui
le font vivre mais plutôt à sa
complexité à son atomisation à son
manque d'intelligibilité ou alors au
manque de coordination qui crée des
parcours 3 hachés et qui ne répondent
pas suffisamment aux besoins des
entreprises
pour les travailleurs en situation de
handicap le parcours d'orientation vers
l'emploi et complexe trop souvent
impersonnel et donc source
d'incompréhension et de déception et
c'est ce qui explique le troisième point
de ce projet de loi notre objectif est
donc de mieux coordonner les acteurs du
service public de l'emploi et
d'améliorer l'accompagnement des
entreprises et des personnes
avant de revenir sur les trois
principaux objectifs les trois
principaux axes de ce projet de loi je
voudrais rappeler que ce projet est
avant tout le fruit d'une méthode de
concertation avec l'ensemble des acteurs
j'ai confiance en septembre dernier une
mission de concertation et de
préfiguration à Thibault qui lui au
commissaire à l'emploi et l'engagement
des entreprises il m'a rendu son rapport
le 17 avril dernier avec une très large
concertation et se rapporte traduit
l'essentiel des principes relevés par la
mission et rendu consensuel par la
concertation nous avons repris ces
principes dans le projet de loi que nous
vous présentons la concertation a aussi
été à l'oeuvre pour l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap le
président de la République a réuni une
conférence nationale du handicap le 26
avril dernier et les mesures proposées
pour l'emploi des personnes handicapées
dans ce cadre sont aussi utiles cette
concertation et chacune des mesures que
je défendrai devant vous a été présentée
à l'occasion des 25 groupes de travail
réunis dans le cadre des préparations de
la préparation des mesures emploi
pilotées par mon ministère pour préparer
la CNH
nous avons donc plusieurs chantiers à
vous proposer avec ce projet de loi le
premier grand chantier c'est je disais
il y a un instant l'amélioration de la
gouvernance du service public de
l'emploi c'est un chantier essentiel
vous le savez car toutes les remontées
de terrain témoignent d'une difficile
adaptation aux problématique locale et
aussi du sentiment que les acteurs ça
parlent pas assez entre eux d'abord nous
mettons donc en place un réseau le
réseau France travail fondé sur des
principes de partenariat et de
coordination et regroupera l'état bien
sûr les collectivités locales les
opérateurs et l'ensemble des acteurs qui
interviennent sur le champ de
l'insertion de la formation et de
l'emploi ce regroupement permettra aux
usagers de mieux identifier la cohérence
entre les acteurs qui agiront demain
sous une même bannière il permettra une
offre de service plus homogène plus
cohérente sur tout le territoire plus
lisible pour les demandeurs d'emploi
comme pour les entreprises pour cela le
projet de loi définit une forme de
patrimoine commun à chacun des membres
du réseau pour mieux le coordonner des
méthodes et des règles de coordination
des critères d'inscription et
d'orientation des référentiels métiers
des référentiels formation tout sera mis
en commun et partager au sein du même
réseau ça ne signifie pas que le projet
serait un grand Big Bang une fusion de
tout en tout bien au contraire mais
simplement d'élaborer des méthodes et
des outils qui puissent être utilisées
par chacun des acteurs dans le cadre de
l'exercice de leur compétences cela sera
rendu notamment possible par la mise en
réseau des systèmes d'information pour
partager les données en tracteur et dans
le cadre de ce patrimoine numérique
comment le système d'information de Pôle
Emploi évoluera en plateforme en
plateforme transvaille accessible à tous
les acteurs et facilitant le travail de
chacun ce sont aussi plus d'informations
pour les collectivités pour les élus
avec des données agrégées sur les
parcours sur les accompagnements qui
seront partagés avec les collectivités
locales avec leurs élus et qui
permettront des comparaisons tant sur
les objectifs que sur les moyens
sans partage de données il n'y a pas de
coordination des interventions ni suivi
des accompagnements et c'est je crois
une avancée concrète qui répond à une
demande de longue date ensuite nous
souhaitons mettre en place une
gouvernance territorialisée et
simplifiée de France travail elle
reposera sur un copilotage entre l'État
et les collectivités locales à chaque
expulsion territoriale pertinent
associant les partenaires sociaux au
niveau national et au niveau régional
cette gouvernance partagée le moyen le
plus sûr d'assurer la cohérence du
réseau tout en réduisant le nombre
d'instances qui existent nous créons
ainsi une nouvelle instance de
gouvernance nationale qui définira les
orientations stratégiques et les
modalités de pilotage du patrimoine
commun le Comité National France
travaille au niveau local des comités
territoriaux assurant un pilotage
régional départemental mais aussi au
niveau des bassins d'emplois et les
collectivités territoriales ils seront
toutes représentés
je souhaite bien sûr
le dire à nouveau devant vous France
travail le projet que je vous propose ne
réduit pas le champ des compétences des
collectivités locales c'est même le
contraire puisque si les régions gardent
toutes leurs prérogatives sur la
formation les départements gardent toute
leur fréquence locative prérogatives sur
l'insertion les communes les EPCI
gardent aussi toute leur vie sur le
champ social la compréhension du réseau
France travail ne signifie pas la
tutelle de l'État au contraire l'État et
les collectivités auront conjointement
la main pour travailler ensemble à
écrire l'orientation des opérateurs et
des partenaires du réseau et au premier
rang duquel
l'opérateur principal qui est
aujourd'hui Pôle Emploi ce ne sont donc
pas moins de compétences mais plus de
visibilité pour les collectivités avec
un pouvoir d'orientation plus fort sur
l'ensemble des enjeux d'insertion et
d'emploi d'ailleurs vous l'avez noté
aucune disposition du texte ne vient
modifier la répartition des compétences
entre l'État et des collectivités et
aucune disposition du texte ne modifie
la répartition des compétences entre les
collectivités elles-mêmes
enfin dans le cadre de la mise en place
du réseau France travail et de sa
gouvernance nous proposons que Pôle
Emploi prenne en charge de nouvelles
missions au service du collectif il sera
l'opérateur chargé de proposer de
coordonner les communs physiques
numériques et méthodologiques du réseau
France travail pour le compte de tous et
on y a de chacun en application des
orientations définies par les comités
par l'État et les collectivités locales
ça ne nous donc pas une recentralisation
puisque cette opérateur principal devra
mettre sa capacité de soutien technique
et opérationnel au service de tous de
produire ce patrimoine commun il y a
étroit et en co-construction avec tous
les acteurs concernés et il inscrira
donc son action en cas des orientations
d'alté définie par la gouvernance à qui
il rendra compte à cet égard je souhaite
souligner que le changement de nom de
Pôle emploi en opérateur France
travaille que propose le gouvernement ne
doit pas être interprété comme une
marque de domination sur les autres
acteurs dans le cadre du réseau je dis
notamment à Madame la rapporteur qui
s'en inquiète à juste titre en lui
disant mais ça renvoie à nos échanges
que nous modifierons le schéma de
présentation pour éviter de donner
graphiquement l'impression qu'un
opérateur serait plus important que les
autres
nous avons en réalité deux objectifs
d'abord marquer l'importance du
changement de positionnement de Pôle
Emploi sa transformation en opérateur
agissant au service du collectif qui
déploie son action dans un cadre
territorialisé et partenariat et je le
dis aussi s'il le souhaite est
uniquement si le souhaite l'émission
locale et les Cap Emploi qui le
souhaitent peuvent se saisir de la
marque france-travail dans leur
dénomination d'autre part nous voulons
rendre plus lisible le réseau pour les
usagers un enjeu auquel nous devons être
sensible au vu de la complexité de la
diversité des actes je sais madame la
rapporteur vous interrogations cela
dénomination ou le changement
dénomination de Pôle emploi en France
travaille nous aurons en débattre pour
je crois essayer d'apporter les
meilleures réponses
par ailleurs dans le cadre de ce réseau
les initiatives locales seront mises au
cœur du nouveau service public de
l'emploi dans chacune de mes visites
dans chacun des départements on me dit
souvent que le réseau de France
travaille existe en réalité déjà ici ou
là grâce à des solucures locales c'est
vrai et France travail les maintiendra
les insérera dans son réseau il est hors
de question de remplacer ce qu'ils
fonctionnent bien ainsi par exemple les
missions locales continueront de jouer
leur rôle central auprès des jeunes en
difficulté nous avons travaillé avec
l'Union nationale des missions locales
nous avons supprimé une mention qui les
inquiétait notamment sur l'exercice de
leurs compétences par délégation de
France travail cela a été supprimé cela
a été souligné l'état continuera de
conventionner directement avec elle en
ce qui concerne la financement et les
collectivités seront toujours aussi
présentes dans leurs instances de
coordination il n'a jamais été question
de fusion ni de remise en cause de leur
statut de leur autonomie et ainsi le
réseau France travail pourra le
préserver
cette inquiétude qui est exprimée par
certaines missions locales je l'entends
je l'entends parce qu'il y a quelques
années le projet d'une fusion avait été
évoqué ce projet n'a pas été mené à
terme et c'est heureux et nous ne
l'avons pas repris et là aussi aucune
disposition du texte n'envisage cette
reprise ou cette idée de fusion
absorption il est essentiel cependant
que les missions locales que Cap emploi
que Pôle emploi soit mieux coordonné
dans leurs actions avec tous les autres
acteurs de l'emploi et mieux outils et
c'est là le principal objectif que nous
poursuivons le deuxième grand objectif
de ce projet de loi et d'améliorer
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et notamment les plus fragiles d'entre
eux nous le savons il fallait plus loin
pour les plus fragiles certains constats
doivent nous alarmer collectivement
ainsi 16% des allocataires du RSA ils
sont inscrits plus de 10 ans après leur
première inscription 18% des
allocataires ne connaissent du RSA que
la location et n'ont aucun organisme de
suivi ni social ni professionnel et la
Cour des comptes l'a montré après 7 ans
7 ans après une première inscription 42%
des allocataires sont encore à locataire
à titre de manière continue ou
récurrente
or nous le savons l'inactivité exclue à
l'isole elle précarise la pauvrie et
l'éloigne chaque jour un peu plus du
travail qui est le plus sur moyen
d'indépendance et d'automie et
d'autonomie de chacun aussi nous voulons
tenir pour de bons la promesse de
solidarité qui est celle du RSA avec une
série de mesures concrètes d'abord
l'ensemble des personnes en recherche
d'emploi seront inscrites auprès de
l'opérateur France travail c'est le
meilleur moyen de garantir en
accompagnement à chacun et d'éviter des
ruptures de parcours et pour les plus
isolés le préjudo à prévoit la
reconnaissance d'une part d'une nouvelle
catégorie d'organismes souvent
associatif chargé de repérer d'aller
vers les personnes qui ne sont plus
suivies pour leur proposer des solutions
d'accompagnement et d'insertion adaptés
ces acteurs seront intégrés au réseau
France travail visa retrouver identifier
accompagné ce qu'on appelle parfois les
invisibles qui malheureusement sont
éloignés très durablement éloignés du
marché de l'emploi
d'autre part nous souhaitons que le
parcours d'accompagnement soit formalisé
dans le cadre d'un contrat d'engagement
rénové et unifié ce nouveau contrat
d'engagement sera proposé à tous les
demandeurs d'emploi quel que soit leur
situation il détaillera les engagements
réciproques de l'organisme référent les
ateliers les actions de formation de
mise en situation professionnelle de
lever des freins à l'emploi et de la
personne accompagnée en termes d'acidité
de participation à ces mêmes activités
il intégrera un plan d'action qui
précise des objectifs d'insertion
sociale et professionnelle du demandeur
d'emploi et après un diagnostic complet
le demandeur d'emploi pourra être
orienté vers un parcours à Visé
d'insertion sociale pour le vrai lever
les freins rencontré en matière de
logement de garde d'enfants de santé de
mobilité avant un parcours d'insertion
professionnelle et lorsque c'est
possible à chaque fois que c'est
possible ces deux parcours devront être
juxtaposées il faudra tenir compte de
l'âge c'est ce que prévoit la loi du
niveau de qualification de la situation
économique du bassin d'emploi des freins
à l'emploi en termes de mobilité ou de
garde d'enfants mais aussi de situations
particulières je pense notamment la
situation des procédons c'est une
manière pour moi de dire combien
j'approuve les modifications apportées
par votre commission sur cet aspect du
texte le régime de contrôle et de
fonction des allocataires du RSA sera
lui aussi rénové avec un nouveau premier
niveau de fonction la suspension
remobilisation qui permettra de
suspendre temporairement la location au
premier manquement sans interrompre
l'accompagnement si la personne respecte
ces engagements elle bénéficiera d'un
versement rétroactif des droits à défaut
le RSA pourrait être comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui supprimer nous ne touchons
pas la radiation telle qu'elle avait été
prévue par la loi de 1988 est telle
qu'elle est mise en oeuvre par les
présidents de conseil départementaux
enfin dans l'esprit du contrat
d'engagement jeune ce nouveau contrat
permettra de proposer un accompagnement
intensif et personnalisé pour les
allocataires du RSA les plus éloignés de
l'emploi France travail proposera ceux
qui ont le plus besoin et selon ce que
permet leur situation personnelle bien
sûr jusqu'à 15 ou 20 heures
hebdomadaires consacré à leur parcours
là aussi d'ateliers de formation ou de
solutions locales
cet accompagnement sera renforcé par la
prise en compte des difficultés de
nature sociale les freins l'emploi que
j'ai déjà évoqué et dont nous voulons
pouvoir les débloquer très concrètement
enfin pour que cet accompagnement puisse
intégrer une offre de formation adaptée
je saisis l'occasion de ce débat pour
dire que nous voulons conforter le
principe de contractualisation plus
réelle entre l'État et les régions pour
la formation et donc la poursuite d'un
plan d'investissement dans les
compétences aux côtés et en complément
de l'investissement des régions nous le
savons ramener vers l'emploi et permis
par la formation et atteindre le plein
emploi passera par la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi et la réponse aux
besoins de compétences des entreprises
et ainsi dans le cadre de ce pic
renouvelé priorité sera donnée au public
les plus fragiles aux métiers en tension
aux formations à distance aux formations
courtes avant embauche tout ce qui a
fait ses preuves au cours du programme
d'investissement du plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
qui s'achètent
enfin monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente le troisième chantier du
projet de loi concerne la poursuite de
l'engagement pour l'emploi des personnes
handicapées les personnes en situation
de handicap rencontre encore trop
difficultés pour accéder ou retourner à
l'emploi et donc nous voulons prolonger
la politique volontariste des dernières
années à travers les mesures concrètes
de la Conférence nationale du handicap
autour de trois axes clairs d'abord
améliorer l'orientation professionnelle
des personnes handicapées en la
confiance au service public de l'emploi
pour se faire nous supprimons
l'orientation vers le marché du
travailleur par les MDPH et
l'orientation en milieu ordinaire
devient un droit un droit universel car
chacun est présumé pouvoir y travailler
aussi le service public de l'emploi
proposera un accompagnement à toute
personne en situation de handicap et
sans emploi qui expriment le souhait
comme pour tous les demandeurs d'emploi
France travail pourra lui proposer un
appui au diagnostic personnalisé pour
déterminer l'environnement professionnel
le plus adapté en fonction de son degré
d'autonomie ça permettra la construction
d'un projet professionnel défini sur la
base d'immersion dans différents
environnements que ce soit des esats des
Entreprises Adaptées des entreprises
ordinaires avec de l'emploi accompagner
ou bien sûr les entreprises nordines et
sur cette base France travail il fera
une préconisation qui pourrait être une
orientation en ESAT prononcée par la
MDPH de cas échéant mais nous changeons
la logique en considérant qu'un
demandeur d'emploi en situation de
handicap et d'abord un demandeur
d'emploi et que l'orientation en milieu
ordinaire est un droit qui doit être
acquis respecter nous souhaitons ainsi
mettre un terme aux orientations
prononcées uniquement sur la base d'un
dossier administratif sans tenir compte
de la réelle capacité et de la réelle
volonté de travail des personnes dans le
même cadre et dans le même temps la
trajectoire de développement de l'emploi
accompagné est conforté et son pilotage
est confiés jusqu'en 2027 au ministère
du travail puisque nous considérons que
l'emploi accompagné qui permet de
soutenir les personnes en situation de
handicap invisible soit devra être
intégré au dispositif du réseau France
travail
deuxième axe pour l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap concernent
l'accès aux droits de ces mêmes
personnes les personnes reconnues
handicapées au titre d'une pension
d'invalidité ou d'une rente d'incapacité
auront ainsi les mêmes droits prévus
dans le code du travail que les
personnes titulaires d'une RQTH sans
passer par la MDPH ainsi les
bénéficiaires d'une obligation d'emploi
pourront être recrutés en entreprise
adaptées bénéficier de l'emploi
accompagné ou avoir une rémunération
majorée en formation professionnelle
sans avoir à passer par la demande d'une
RQTH
de la même manière ou avec la même idée
les conditions de travail des personnes
en ESAT vont évoluer et l'endroits
sociaux convergeront avec les droits
individuels et collectifs des salariés
je pense à la prise en charge de la
mutuelle du transport de missile travail
mais aussi aux droits de grève ou au
droit syndicales c'est une amélioration
considérable pour approcher concrètement
l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap de celui du reste de la
population sans remettre en cause la
protection contre le licenciement dont
elle bénéficie enfin nous vous nous
voulons favoriser l'engagement des
employeurs privés et public ainsi pour
accompagner les employeurs dans le
recrutement de personnes en situation de
handicap le modèle des Entreprises
Adaptées travaille temporaire les
contrats déterminésit tremplin jusqu'à
leur expérimentaux pourront entrer de
manière pérenne dans le code du travail
et j'aurais à vous proposer deux
amendements le premier pour compléter le
passeport numérique qui est géré par la
Caisse des dépôts et intégrée dans ce
passeport numérique autour des
compétences la totalité des aménagements
dont a bénéficier une personne au type
de son handicap pour en attirer une
traçabilité le deuxième pour permettre
aux entreprises qui le souhaitent de
donner sans difficulté sociale ou
fiscale les aménagements qu'elle aurait
acquis pour permettre le recrutement et
l'emploi d'une personne en situation de
handicap qui serait amenée à la quitter
le dernier chantier est celui du service
public de la petite enfance mais mon
collègue Jean-Christophe combe
interviendra dans un instant pour vous
le présenter je souhaite conclure pour
dire que cette réforme sera aussi
enrichie par vos discussions comme elle
a été en commission je pense par exemple
à la prise en compte des projets je lui
dis ou des représentants des usagers
elle est importance donnée à la réponse
aux besoins de recrutement des
entreprises mais on ferme notamment pour
ce qu'ils vont faire le recrutement de
personnes en situation de handicap ou au
lien avec l'éducation nationale à la
pérennisation de l'organisation de
l'emploi accompagné sous forme de
plateforme plateforme départementale de
service intégrés ou encore aux
compétences dont vous allez dont vous
avez voulu doter le Comité National
France travail il est bien sûr quelques
dispositions adoptées par votre
commission qui feront débats qui peuvent
faire divergence mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre et là aussi je
l'espère de trouver les voies d'un
consensus
en conclusion je souhaiterais simplement
souligner que toute la mise en oeuvre de
France travail ne relève naturellement
pas de la loi nous avons 18
expérimentations départementales pour
l'accompagnement rénové du RSA qui nous
permettront jusqu'à fin 2024 de pouvoir
échanger et participer sur les bonnes
pratiques ça ne relève pas de la loi ni
même du réglementaire mais plutôt des
modalités d'accompagnement et de gestion
nous avons aussi des préfigurations avec
les régions nous avons signé des
protocoles de préfiguration avec d'ores
et déjà cinq régions une sixième région
a validé son principe par une
délibération à la fin de la semaine
passée j'étais en Franche-Comté vendredi
pour signer le protocole de
préfiguration avec la région Bourgogne
Franche-Comté afin d'anticiper pour le
partage d'informations l'amélioration du
service aux entreprises et
l'amélioration de la connaissance des
dispositifs de la même manière nous
allons améliorer l'offre de service à
destination des entreprises de manière
très opérationnelle dans le cadre de
cette configuration sans que ça relève
du champ de la loi je suis convaincu
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
qu'avec ces trois axes la gouvernance
améliorer un service un service public
de l'emploi rénové l'accompagnement des
plus éloignés de l'emploi et le fait de
faciliter de simplifier l'accès à
l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap nous nous dotons d'outils
nécessaires utile pour aller vers le
Pôle emploi et un emploi de bonne
qualité pour tous merci à toutes et à
tous pour votre attention
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
maintenant monsieur Jean-Christophe con
ministre des Solidarités de l'autonomie
des personnes handicapées
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chez Olivier madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs alors en
cette période de début de congés
estivaux j'ai une pensée particulière
pour les millions de familles qui
partent en vacances avec leurs enfants
mais aussi pour celles pour qui cela ne
sera peut-être pas le cas les raisons en
sont diverses mais le ministre en charge
de la petite enfance et des familles que
je suis ne s'y résignent jamais cette
année encore avec les collectivités
locales avec les acteurs associatifs
mobilisés nous ferons en sorte d'aider
autant d'enfants que possible à profiter
de ces moments de respiration et
d'épanouissement personnel à découvrir
de nouveaux horizons
je referme dès à présent ce qui en
réalité est plus qu'une parenthèse car
en parlant là de difficultés d'accès de
certaines familles à des loisirs ou des
services précis d'inégalités entre les
foyers j'évoque aussi les enjeux
d'équilibre entre la vie professionnelle
et la vie familiale des parents d'accès
des enfants à des temps de socialisation
de soutien et d'accompagnement à la
parentalité autant de défis qui
résonnent bien sûr avec l'article 10 du
présent en projet de loi qui vise à
mettre en oeuvre le service public de la
petite enfance dont les contours
figuraient dans le programme du
président de la République et ont été
précisés le 1er juin dernier par la
première ministre à ce titre j'ai aussi
une pensée particulière pour ces
familles qui à l'issue des commissions
d'attribution des dernières semaines
abordent les vacances sans certitude
d'avoir ensuite une solution d'accueil
pour leur enfant cette réforme est pour
elle pour tous ses parents qui ont connu
l'inquiétude de la rentrée on craint les
conséquences que cela de t'avoir y
compris en termes d'accès au marché du
travail c'est pour cette c'est pourquoi
cette réforme porte une double ambition
d'abord assurer le développement en
nombre suffisant de place d'accueil pour
apporter une solution adaptée à chaque
famille et ensuite garantir une haute
qualité d'accueil à tous les enfants
pour lui donner forme le gouvernement a
pris le temps tout au long de ces 10
derniers mois d'une large concertation
elle a été en grande partie menée par
Elisabeth laitier mère adjointe à Nancy
en charge la petite enfance pendant 24
ans experte référente au sein de
l'Association des maires de France et
présidente du comité de filière petite
enfance à qui j'avais confié le pilotage
local du volley du Conseil national de
la refondation dédié à la petite enfance
pour bâtir cette réforme nous sommes
partis de quatre fondamentaux d'abord
les besoins des enfants et leurs parents
ensuite les attentes des professionnels
et les messages qu'ils avaient à nous
passer
mais aussi les demandes des acteurs du
bloc communal communes rurales
urbaine intercommunalité en première
ligne sur le sujet et enfin en
conséquence l'organisation de la vie
générale perfectible des compétences des
différents acteurs publics les besoins
des parents tout d'abord sont clairs car
ils les formulent dès que nous les
interrons à ce titre les résultats de
l'enquête par an réalisés par Ipsos en
avril dernier pour le ministère des
solidarités sont éclairants il montre à
quel point la recherche d'un mode
d'accueil reste trop souvent un parcours
du combattant 61% des parents déclarant
que cela avait constitué une source de
stress importante voire très importante
pour 28% d'entre eux répondre aux
besoins de ses parents en galère je me
permets cette expression qu'elle est car
elle est un stricte reflet de leur vécu
et donc bien une priorité sociale la
réponse à cette priorité ne peut exister
sans l'action déterminée de
professionnels dévoués qu'il nous faut
davantage soutenir là encore les
attentes sont claires et les défis
nombreux environ 10 000 professionnels
font aujourd'hui défaut au sein des
crèches et 120 000 assistants maternels
pourraient cesser leur activité d'ici à
2030 s'ajoutant au 40 000 qui l'ont déjà
fait entre 2017 et 2021 nous avons
évidemment besoin de professionnels
formés en nombre suffisant et donc
épanoui pour cela il nous faut restaurer
l'attractivité des métiers de la petite
enfance pour réenclencher une dynamique
vertueuse favorisant les recrutements
revalorisation salariale sens au travail
qualité de vie et perspective
d'évolution et pour la première fois
l'État sera justement présent pour
accompagner ses revalorisations
salariales dans le secteur de la petite
enfance la convention d'objectif et de
gestion entre l'État et la Caisse
nationale d'allocations familiales que
j'ai signé ce matin même et qui avait
été adopté très largement le 4 juillet
dernier par le Conseil d'A ministration
de la CNAF prévoit la mobilisation de
plus de 200 millions d'euros
conditionnés à l'amélioration de leur
socle de droits sociaux
au-delà de ce soutien aux professionnels
l'ampleur du défi auquel nous faisons
face appel une action résolue fondée sur
des objectifs communs et une mise en
cohérence de l'ensemble des actions
c'est sur cette base que j'ai engagé
très tôt des travaux associant
étroitement les collectivités locales et
leurs représentants
s'agissant d'une politique partenariale
faisant intervenir tous les échelons de
compétences l'État les communes et leurs
groupements les régions les départements
il était bien sûr indispensable de créer
un véritable espace de dialogue et de
co-construction cette parie que nous
faisons avec cette réforme son volet
quantitatif se retrouve donc dans ce
projet de loi sur le plein emploi et il
y a toute sa place tout simplement parce
qu'on estime à plus de 150 000 personnes
principalement des femmes qui sont
empêchées de prendre ou reprendre un
emploi faute de mode d'accueil pour leur
jeunes enfants
le dispositif qui vous est proposé vient
avant tout conforter la compétence des
communes désignées autorité
organisatrice en matière d'accueil du
jeune enfant chef de fil naturel les
communes et intercommunalités pourront
ainsi mieux piloter l'offre du
territoire par exemple en refusant les
installations de structure qui ne leur
semblent pas correspondre aux attentes
et besoins locaux ou en aidant les
parents et assistant maternel qui en
ressentent le besoin à s'acquitter de
leur formalités administrative
pour exercer leur nouvelle
responsabilité par exemple en matière de
formalisation d'un schéma d'accueil du
jeune enfant pour les communes de plus
de 3500 habitants où l'installation d'un
relais petite enfance pour celle de plus
de 10000 habitants les communes pourront
compter sur un soutien renforcé et
adapté à leurs besoins la nouvelle coche
prévoit ainsi près de 6 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat pour atteindre les
objectifs du SPPE du service public de
la petite enfance ces financements qui
seront déployés très rapidement
permettront de garantir aux familles une
réponse à leurs besoins d'accueil
partout sur le territoire il viendront
épauler les communes et les
intercommunalités avec non seulement des
moyens directs en investissement pour
faire sortir de terre de nouvelles
places d'accueil mais aussi et surtout
des aides au fonctionnement massivement
renforcés en réponse à des demandes de
longue date
de même parce que cela avait été remonté
par de nombreux mers de nouveaux
soutiens en ingénierie seront mis en
place avec plus de 100 ETP pour
accompagner les communes qui le
souhaitent c'est accompagnement massif
de l'État aura d'autant plus de poids
qu'il viendra crédibiliser la stratégie
nationale de la politique d'accueil du
jeune enfant dont je vous proposerai le
rétablissement et qui doit permettre de
poser les besoins en nouveaux
professionnels pour les années à venir
et nous offrir une vision globale des
enjeux personne ne connaît mieux ses
enjeux de planification de l'offre que
les communes et c'est bien pour cela que
l'article 10 vise avant tout à conforter
leur rôle central mais aussi à clarifier
leur relation avec les autres
collectivités et la branche famille de
la sécurité sociale c'est également pour
cela et en réponse aux préoccupations
que vous avez été un certain nombre à
formuler que je vous proposerai deux
approfondissements pendant nos
discussions d'abord pour donner une plus
grande place à la concertation avec les
collectivités locales dans le cadre de
la automatisation de la stratégie
nationale que je viens d'évoquer et
ensuite pour mettre à profit les
prochaines semaines avec un dialogue
renforcé avec les collectivités sur les
différents volets de cette réforme
notamment en matière de qualité
d'accueil car si elle comporte un
important voler quantitatif dont je
viens de résumer les grandes lignes
cette réforme s'appuie aussi sur un
renforcement impératif de la qualité
d'accueil du jeune enfant pour lequel la
parole des collectivités et notamment
des départements doit être central et
c'est tout l'objet des annonces que j'ai
faites il y a deux semaines il nous
faudra ainsi collectivement restaurer
l'attractivité du secteur j'en ai parlé
améliorer la qualité institutionnelle de
l'accueil et prévenir le risque de la
maltraitance en réformant les règles
d'organisation et de financement des
modes d'accueil
et enfin en installant un réflexe de
vigilance en renforçant le système
d'alerte de contrôle et de suivi des
suspicions de maltraitance mission dont
le gouvernement a confié la
préfiguration à Florence Dabin qui est
présidente du conseil départemental de
Maine-et-Loire
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs c'est bien en avançant de
front sur ces trois axes qualités
quantité moyen que nous pourrons non
seulement concrétiser la promesse du
service public de la petite enfance mais
surtout répondre aux immenses défis
auxquelles nous faisons face défi du
soutien aux parents et aux
professionnels défis du développement de
l'enfant avec une réforme pilier de la
politique des 1000 premiers jours défi
enfin de la natalité car en mettant fin
au parcours du combattant des familles
le service public de la petite enfance
est aussi un investissement d'avenir un
levier de confiance et de soutien pour
les parents d'aujourd'hui et de demain
c'est ce à quoi nous appelle l'Union
nationale des associations familiales
dont la présidente Marie-Andrée blanc
n'était autre que la Cour rapporteur de
la vie rendue en mars 2022 par le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental sur le service public de
la petite enfance sur lequel l'ensemble
de la concertation a été fondée c'est
donc une réforme majeure aux multiples
une facettes sociales sociétales
économique politique qui vous est
proposé aujourd'hui ces contours dépasse
ceux de l'article 10 de ce projet de loi
avec un plan pour la qualité de
l'accueil et des revalorisations
salariales mais c'est avec les
évolutions de gouvernance prévues par
cet article 10 confortant le bloc
communal clarifiant c'est modalités
d'intervention que l'ensemble de ces
efforts trouveront pleinement leur effet
leur efficacité et répondront aux
attentes des familles je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
maintenant madame la Présidente Pascal
grunis rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales pour 10 minutes vous
avez la parole madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres même la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues ce projet de loi pour
objectif de réduire le chômage par deux
leviers principaux d'une part unifier
renforcer l'accompagnement de toutes les
personnes dépourvues d'emploi en donnant
une portée plus effective à leurs
engagements et d'autre part faire
coopérer les acteurs de l'emploi et de
l'insertion au sein d'un réseau France
travail cadre de gouvernance rénové
développant des outils partagés nous
souscrivons à cet objectif et partageons
les constats de la mission de
préfiguration de France travail un
accompagnement inégal des personnes sans
emploi et un suivi insuffisamment
coordonné toutefois sans moyens pour y
parvenir ce projet est illusoire
l'intensification de l'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi nécessite des
financements à la hauteur ce que ne
prévoit pas le texte la coordination des
acteurs et l'harmonisation des pratiques
ne saurait transformé en cadre
contraignant et uniforme imposées par
l'État enfin changer les outils et les
méthodes du service public de l'emploi
suppose si l'on veut qu'il soit
réellement adapté d'associer à leur
conception et à leurs pilotage
l'ensemble des acteurs de terrain qui
doivent préserver leur prérogatives je
pense par exemple aux missions locales
lutter efficacement contre le chômage
implique de s'attaquer aux principaux
freins périphériques à l'emploi et le
projet de loi consacre un article à la
garde d'enfants mais il reste bien
d'autres freins à traiter le logement la
santé l'éducation ou encore l'accès à la
médecine du travail c'est dans cet
esprit que la commission des affaires
sociales a modifié le texte concernant
la gouvernance la Commission a approuvé
la création d'un réseau France travail à
l'article 4 il réunira l'ensemble des
acteurs du service public de l'emploi et
de l'insertion afin de renforcer leur
coordination et de favoriser une prise
en charge harmonisée de l'ensemble des
personnes sans
nous avons précisé que les acteurs du
réseau devront répondre aux besoins des
employeurs en complément de leur mission
d'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et pour que les outils communs soient
définis de manière concertée qu'il
puisse être adaptées au niveau local
nous avons voulu renforcer les
prérogatives des comités de pilotage
créés au niveau national et territorial
la Commission a ainsi prévu que l'État
les collectivités territoriales et les
partenaires sociaux qui siégeront dans
le Comité National France travail
identifieront les besoins plus
ré-annuels de financement pour la mise
en oeuvre des missions d'accompagnement
il ne s'agit pas là de fixer par avance
le budget de l'État ou des collectivités
mais de donner davantage de visibilité
aux acteurs nous avons aussi souhaité
que l'ensemble des référentiels et
casier des charges notamment pour
l'orientation des bénéficiaires ou pour
l'interopérabilité des systèmes
d'information soit définie par ce comité
plutôt que par arrêté ministériel
au niveau local nous avons considéré
qu'il fallait mieux associer les
associations d'élus pour la constitution
des comités sans figer dans la loi la
composition complète des instances de
gouvernance il convient de laisser des
marges de manœuvre aux acteurs locaux
enfin au sein de ce réseau nous avons
approuvé le rôle donné à Pôle Emploi
d'assurer des missions d'appui et de
conception d'outils au profit des
acteurs du réseau dans la mesure où il
se conformera aux orientations définies
par l'État les collectivités et les
partenaires sociaux en revanche la
Commission n'a pas souhaité que Pôle
Emploi prenne le nom d'opérateurs France
travail
l'opérateur ne saurait avoir le même nom
que le réseau des acteurs de l'emploi au
risque de créer des confusions sur les
rôles de chacun et de laisser planer une
suspicion de hiérarchie entre les
différents acteurs j'ai beaucoup entendu
cette crainte
le projet de loi ne modifie pas la
dénomination des missions locales ou des
CAP EMPLOI alors pourquoi Pôle Emploi
changerait-il de nom Pôle Emploi est
aujourd'hui bien identifié par les
usagers et ce changement de nom sera
coûteux alors que d'importants moyens
sont nécessaires pour accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi janvier au
disposition qui concerne
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et des bénéficiaires du RSA afin que
toutes les personnes sans emploi puisse
entrer dans un parcours d'accompagnement
vers l'emploi et être orienté vers
l'organisme le plus adapté à leur
situation la Commission a approuvé à
l'article premier le principe de
l'inscription automatique sur la liste
des demandeurs d'emploi de toutes les
personnes en recherche d'emploi y
compris les bénéficiaires du RSA
la Commission a également adoptée
l'article 2 qui tente à unifier les
droits et devoirs de toutes les
personnes inscrites sur la liste
demandeurs d'emploi au sein d'un nouveau
contrat d'engagement toutefois cet
article ne sera divisé pas l'objectif
pourtant afficher par le gouvernement de
mobiliser les personnes éloignées de
l'emploi pendant une durée hebdomadaire
près définie la Commission a souhaité
que le contrat d'engagement précise la
durée des hebdomadaire d'activité qu'il
sera demandé aux demandeurs d'emploi
d'accomplir et cette durée devrait être
d'au moins 15 heures
concernant plus particulièrement les
bénéficiaires du RSA la Commission a
validé la création d'une sanction de
suspension du versement de la location
dite suspension remobilisation à
l'article 3 en revanche afin de ne pas
compromettre l'efficacité du dispositif
elle a limité les sommes pouvant être
versées rétroactivement lorsque le
bénéficiaire se conforme à nouveau à ses
obligations à trois mois de RSA
de plus la Commission a souhaité que le
président du conseil départemental soit
toujours compétent pour prendre la
décision de sanctionner un bénéficiaire
du RSA mais sa position pourra évoluer
sur ce point une corde de rappel pouvant
être
utile
l'article 7 donne compétences à l'état
pour organiser des marchés nationaux en
matière de formation ouverte et à
distance Fouad et précise que la mise en
oeuvre des pactes régionaux
d'investissement dans les compétences le
prix devra désormais prendre en compte
les besoins des entreprises et des
secteurs qui ont des difficultés de
recrutement
si la commission partage cette attention
besoin des filières en tension elle n'a
pas souhaité conserver la possibilité de
marcher nationaux pour la formation
verte et à distance et a tenu à préciser
que l'offre de formation des demandeurs
d'emploi proposé par l'État doit prendre
en compte les besoins
identifiés par les acteurs régionaux via
les comités régionaux de formation et
d'orientation professionnelle dit très
fort le projet de loi contient également
des mesures en faveur de l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap
conformément à certains des engagements
pris lors de la dernière conférence
nationale du handicap ainsi l'article 8
permettra de faciliter les démarches des
travailleurs en situation de handicap en
étendant à toutes les catégories de
bénéficiaires de l'obligation d'emploi
les droits associés à la reconnaissance
de l'acadité de pour travailleur
handicapé la RQTH la Commission à
adopter des amendements rétablissant la
prise en compte de la lourdeur du
handicap pour moduler la contribution de
l'employeur à la Gifi et permettant de
prendre en notre titre de l'obligation
d'emploi les jeunes en situation de
handicap qui ne bénéficient pas d'une
RQTH l'article 9 fait évoluer les droits
des travailleurs en établissement au
Service d'Aide par le Travail les esats
dans le sens d'une convergence avec les
droits des salariés il s'agit de mesure
d'équité en faveur de ces travailleurs
en situation de handicap que la
Commission a soutenue toutefois elle
pose la question de la capacité des
esates à les prendre en charge alors que
ces structures sont déjà fragiles il est
donc nécessaire que le gouvernement
donne des garanties sur le soutien qu'il
entend apporter à ces structures j'en
viens enfin la gouvernance de la
politique d'accueil du jeune enfant nous
avons approuvé l'octroi aux communes du
rôle d'autorité organisatrice de
l'accueil du jeune enfant il s'agit en
réalité de reconnaître une compétence
qu'elles exercent déjà largement les
mères ont à cœur de répondre aux besoins
et aux attentes des familles ils le font
déjà dans la mesure de leur capacité car
confié aux communes de nouvelles
compétences doit accompagner de
compensation financière nous attendons
des engagements du gouvernement de ce
point de vue nous avons en revanche
supprimer de cet article 10 la
définition par arrêter ministériel d'une
stratégie nationale sur l'accueil du
jeûne enfant considérant que le
gouvernement n'a pas besoin de la loi
pour prendre de telles orientations nous
avons aussi supprimé la possibilité
donnée au préfet de ce substituer à la
commune en cas de manquement cette
procédure n'est pas acceptable nous
pouvons je crois faire confiance aux
maires pour répondre aux besoins des
familles au total la Commission a
modifié le texte pour le rendre plus
effectif et plus adapté aux besoins
locaux je vous invite donc à l'adopter
et je vous remercie pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous remercie infiniment pour ce
respect au-delà d'ailleurs du respect du
temps de parole merci nous passons à la
discussion des deux motions
et je précise tout de suite que j'ai été
saisi sur les deux motions d'une demande
de scrutin public merci de vous y
préparer
la première motion était déposée par
mesdames Eliane assassy Katia pour
sopoli Laurence Cohen et les membres du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste sur une motion distribuée
sous le numéro 457 tendant à opposer
l'exception d'y recevabilité au texte en
discussion la parole est à madame la
Présidente Eliana Saci pour 10 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ce
projet de loi dont nous débattons dans
la précipitation d'une session
extraordinaire bien chargée poursuit un
premier objectif qui consiste à
renforcer les contrôles des chômeurs et
les sanctions des bénéficiaires du
revenu de solidarité active ce texte
étant décalage avec la volonté
d'apaisement affichée par le Président
de la République
le gouvernement fait comme si le 27 juin
dernier un jeune de 17 ans n'avait pas
été tué par un policier à Nanterre
déclenchant une flambée de violences
dans les quartiers de l'ensemble de la
métropole mais également en outre-mer en
proposant de conditionner le versement
du RSA à 15 à 20h d'activités par
semaine vous stigmatisez les plus
précaires c'est un véritable
anachronisme de l'urgence politique et
de l'injure faite à celles et ceux qui
essaient de survivre avec rappelons-le
534 euros par mois la réponse politique
à la colère exprimée dans nos quartiers
devraient relever d'un discours
d'égalité de solidarité de la République
comment voulez-vous que les jeunes des
quartiers mais plus généralement la
jeunesse première victime de la
précarisation qui subissent les
discriminations au quotidien retrouve
confiance dans la République et ses
représentants
ce projet de loi censé atteindre le
plein emploi devrait mettre en place des
dispositions pour baisser le chômage en
priorité là où il est le plus fort et
permettre d'engager la construction de
vrais parcours professionnel à l'opposé
de l'ubérisation du travail c'est à dire
dans les territoires ultramarins et dans
nos quartiers des villes populaires je
rappelle que selon l'Observatoire
national des politiques de la ville le
taux de chômage est de 18% dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville
contre 7% en moyenne nationale les
jeunes de moins de 30 ans subissent un
taux de chômage de 30%. et ceux qui
trouvent un boulon ont le plus souvent
des contrats précaires pour des postes
d'ouvriers ou d'employés en quoi votre
projet promptement affiché comme relatif
au plein emploi répondit à cette
situation
selon la CGT Île-de-France le suivi
actif des demandeurs d'emploi c'est
traduit par une augmentation de la
charge du travail des conseillers Pôle
Emploi entre 2020 et 2023 dans mon
département la Seine-Saint-Denis le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi à suivre
par conseiller à doubler il est passé de
250 à 500 tandis que le nombre de
professionnels accompagnant les
bénéficiaires du RSA a été diminué par 3
depuis 1990 désormais un professionnel
doit suivre sans allocataire le premier
obstacle à l'emploi pour ces jeunes ce
sont les discriminations qu'il subissent
à l'embauche alors plutôt que de les
stigmatiser comme la fait l'ancien
patron du Medef en déclarant que le
premier employeur de la
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est le trafic de
drogue il ferait mieux d'agir pour que
les entreprises dépassent les
stéréotypes car les discriminations
expliquent largement le taux de chômage
des jeunes dans les quartiers populaires
cette situation remet en cause l'article
6 de la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 qui
prévoit je cite que la loi doit être la
même pour tous mon groupe a fait le
choix de déposer cette motion pendant à
opposer l'exception des recevabilité car
cette loi comporte des mesures non
conformes à la Constitution en premier
lieu la création du contrat d'engagement
contrevient à la Lina onze du Préambule
de la Constitution du 27 octobre 46 qui
prévoit je cite que tout être humain qui
en raison de son âge de son état
physique ou mental de la situation
économique se trouve dans l'incapacité
de travailler à le droit d'obtenir de la
collectivité des moyens convenables
d'existence le droit d'obtenir des
moyens convenables d'existence ne peut
être soumis à condition or l'article 2
du projet de loi prévoit pour les
chômeurs l'obligation d'assiduité de
participation active aux actions
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
et l'article 3 prévoit pour les
bénéficiaires du revenu de sol sécurité
active la réalisation d'heures
d'activité dont la non-réalisation
entraîne la suppression voire la
suppression du versement du RSA à
l'évidence cette conditionnalité remet
en cause l'accès aux filets de sécurité
minimale que la collectivité verse aux
femmes et aux hommes les plus en
difficulté le contrat d'engagement remet
en cause par ailleurs les droits acquis
par les assurés sociaux en contrepartie
de leur cotisations sociales ce texte
porte donc une atteinte manifeste à nos
principes constitutionnels il suffit de
considérer le préambule de 46 comme un
texte témoin non contraignant or il
édicte bien au contraire les fondements
de la République qui se voulaient
sociale au sortir de la résistance il
est grand temps de rétablir de leur
établir dans sa plénitude selon Lucas
Chancel économiste spécialiste des
inégalités je cite le discours du
gouvernement s'inscrit en réalité dans
la très longue histoire de la
culpabilité des pauvres dont les buts
dont le but est de réduire les
ressources allouées aux aides cette
recherche constante des économies sur le
dos des plus fragiles et des plus
précaires et d'autant plus injuste et
inacceptable que les plus riches et les
plus puissants sont épargnés par de
telles mesures de contrôle et de
sanctions le de poids de mesure
concernant ceux d'en haut et ceux d'en
bas n'est qu'une étincelle pour une
reprise de la violence sociale qui s'est
exprimée avant-hier lors de la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites hier dans nos quartiers et nul
ne sait où elle pourra rejaillir demain
les sanctions envisagées par le
gouvernement et renforcé par la majorité
sénatoriale ne semble pas avoir tenu
compte de l'étude d'impact du projet de
loi qui précise que je l'ai lu la
détermination des obligations et du
régime de sanctions applicable au
bénéficiaires du RSA doit tenir compte
de l'exigence constitutionnelle qui fait
du Revenu de Solidarité Active le
premier le dernier filet de sécurité
pour les personnes qui ne tirent que des
ressources
de leur travail ou des droits qu'ils ont
acquis en travaillant ou qui sont privés
d'emplois fin de citation nous
considérons pour notre part que les
obligations contenues dans le texte et
la gravité des sanctions ne respecte pas
cette exigence constitutionnelle en
deuxième lieu le projet de loi prévoit
de conditionner la co-présidence des
comités territoriaux de France travail à
la signature de la charte d'engagement
par les représentants des exécutifs
territoriaux nous estimons que cette
nouvelle conditionnalité dans la
gouvernance de France travail remet en
cause la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales prévues à
l'article 72 de la Constitution qui
prévoit que dans les conditions prévues
par la loi les collectivités
s'administrent librement par des
conseils élus et disposent d'un pouvoir
réglementaire pour l'exercice de leurs
compétences la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat ne s'y est pas trompé
en supprimant la charte d'engagement et
sa signature et ça signature comme
condition de co-présidence des comités
territoriaux le gouvernement ayant
déposé un amendement visant à rétablir
cette charte d'engagement il est fort à
craindre que la charte d'engagement
entre France travaille et les
collectivités territoriales puissent
revenir dans la navette par le montant
en troisième lieu l'article 9 qui
concerne des droits nouveaux au
travailleuses et aux travailleurs en
établissement et services aide par le
travail les esats maintient une
inégalité de situation et de droit entre
les personnes en situation de handicap
et l'ensemble de la population refusant
d'accorder le statut de salarié et de
l'ensemble des droits afférents à ce
statut le gouvernement actuel comme les
précédents méconnaient le principe de
l'article 6 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen qui disposent
je cite encore la loi d’avoir être la
même pour tous soit qu'elle protège soit
qu'elle punissent tous les citoyens
étant égaux à ses yeux sont également
admissibles à toute dignité place et
emploi public selon leur capacité et
sans votre distinction que celle de
leurs vertus et de leur talents fin de
citation le gouvernement apporterait
certains progrès pour les travailleurs
handicapés en leur accordant le droit
d'adhérer à un syndicat le droit de
grève et la prise en charge par les
établissements d'une complémentaire
santé mais ces droits supplémentaires
n'en font pas moins des droits minima
pour les travailleurs handicapés qui
sont toujours considérés comme des
handicapés avant d'être considérés comme
des travailleurs rien ne justifie cette
rupture d'égalité avec l'ensemble des
salariés comment justifier qu'un
travailleur handicapé soit payé 5 euros
de l'heure tandis qu'un travailleur non
handicapé soit payé à minimum 9 euros de
l'heure la société doit accorder des
droits et des protections
supplémentaires au plus fragiles et pas
l'inverse ce projet de loi constitue un
recul enfin pour le service public de
l'emploi et de l'accompagnement des
privés d'emplois le passage au tout
numérique de France travail va aggraver
la fracture existante pour les bén
éficiaires les plus fragiles selon le
dernier rapport de la Défenseur des
droits je cite un tiers des personnes
sont éloignées du numérique et
constatent par ailleurs une
déshumanisation des services publics
nous craignons que ce texte contribue
donc à creuser les inégalités tout en
renforçant les contrôles et les
sanctions des plus fragiles et c'est
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons que
j'appelle l'ensemble du Sénat à adopter
cette motion et à rejeter ce texte je
vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président
bien entendu on va y mettre un avis
défavorable je vais pas m'attarder sur
les doutes sur la conformité du texte à
la Constitution qui semble artificiel
voilà
les les droitiers devoirs existent
depuis la création des minima sociaux le
revenu de minimum d'insertion le RMI a
toujours été associé à des engagements
réciproques en vue de l'insertion des
bénéficiaires qui étaient déjà
formalisés par un contrat c'est aussi
depuis sa création la philosophie du RSA
et qui est reprise également dans ce
texte donc la concrétisation de cette
notion d'engagement sont été plutôt
formels que réelle et elle reste
insuffisamment tourné vers l'emploi je
crois que ici nous pouvons partager
quand même que beaucoup de personnes
souhaitent arriver à l'emploi en
revanche on est conscient bien entendu
qu'il y a des freins qui a des
difficultés et donc qui a un
accompagnement social qui doit être
mieux fait et pour cela bien entendu
nous posons aussi les questions de du
financement en fait pour mieux
accompagner mais en tout cas pour nous
le travail c'est plutôt l'émancipation
l'insertion dans la vie sociale et donc
nous émettons un avis défavorable
merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur le Président la vie du
gouvernement et par essence défavorable
sur cette notion de renvoi du texte qui
présente au Sénat sur les questions de
constitutionnalité la vie du Conseil
d'État a permis de voir que aucun doute
n'était évoqué à ce sujet là et sur les
questions de libre administration que
vous avez évoquées mesdames sénatrice il
n'y a aucune difficulté non plus puisque
aucune des dispositions du texte ne
remet en cause les compétences des
collectivités tant dans leur répartition
entre l'État et les collectivités contre
les collectivités elles-mêmes ou encore
dans les modalités d'exercice de ces
mêmes compétences la coprésidence donne
au contraire aux collectivités la
possibilité de participer à la
définition des sensation qui
s'imposeront à l'opérateur principal qui
est aujourd'hui Pôle Emploi ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui ils sont plutôt
une compétence nouvelle ou en tout cas
une possibilité nouvelle qu'une
possibilité en moi sur la question de la
conditionnalité je pense qu'il faut
reprendre si vous le permettez les
choses dans l'ordre le texte ne
conditionne pas l'accès au RSA à
l'exercice de 15 à 20h d'activités et si
je dis reprends les choses dans l'ordre
c'est pour rappeler que le RSA est de
droit lorsque un homme ou une femme un
foyer n'a plus de ressources suffisantes
c'est le principe même et l'essence du
RMI lorsqu'on parlait de minimum de
subsistance par contre ce qui est écrit
dans le texte et conformément à la
philosophie de la loi 1988 c'est que
lorsque vous demandez le RSA et que vous
êtes éligible il y a une nécessité qu'il
faut qu'il faut donner de la vigueur une
obligation qui est la signature d'un
contrat d'engagement ce contrat
d'engagement il vient une fois que vous
avez eu accès au RSA et qu'un diagnostic
doit être situation a été fait nous
souhaitons que le diagnostic soit le
plus souvent à deux voies sociales et
professionnel pour garantir un bon
accompagnement et dans ce cas là il y a
définition d'un contrat la loi précise
les modalités des finitions du et c'est
le non respect du contrat élaboré entre
l'organisme de référence et la locataire
du RSA qui entraîne une possibilité de
sanction avec la suspension
remobilisation que l'on a proposé et
enfin troisième point vous avez évoqué
d'entrée d'emblée dans votre
présentation le risque de stigmatisation
je crois que c'est tout l'inverse en
réalité la vraie stigmatisation c'est de
considérer que l'octroi de 534 euros ou
607 parce qu'on parle du RSA majoré à
une personne seule suffirait être à
rendre la société qui est de son devoir
solidarité je considère que nous sommes
kit de notre devoir de solidarité
lorsqu'on a aidé à sortir du RSA et
regagner l'emploi et dans le maximum de
fois de possibilités à aller vers
l'emploi vous avez dit madame la
sénatrice que la part des crédits
consacrés à l'insertion avait
extraordinairement baissé c'est une
réalité en 1988 la loi disait qu'il y
avait obligation de consacrer 20% des
crédits consacrés au RSI au RMI pardon à
la question de l'insertion en 1999 cette
fraction a été ramenée à 16% et en 2004
avec la décentralisation de la gestion
du RSA l'obligation a été levée et il
faut dire de manière très honnête que
depuis 2004 en matière de financement du
RSA et de répartition des financements
entre l'État et les départements aucune
des majorités qui s'est succédé n'a tenu
l'engagement initial de 2004 et
généralement quand nous étions dans
l'opposition trouver ça insupportable
dans la majorité relativement soutenable
donc regardons les choses en face c'est
la raison pour laquelle dans le rapport
Thibault guili comme dans les
engagements que j'ai pris une part des
moyens supplémentaires consacrés à la
mise en place de France travail doit
aussi être orienté vers les départements
pour leur permettre de renforcer les
moyens en matière d'insertion et
d'accompagnement des allocataires donc
la vie est défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre
j'ai été saisi comme je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure d'une demande au scrutin
public sur cette notion d'y recevabilité
je vous rappelle que la ville de la
commission est défavorable la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public le scrutin
public est ouvert
je ne demande à voter le scrutin est
clos
votre temps 344 exprimés 279 pour 27
contre 252 le Sénat n'a pas adopté et
nous passons à la discussion de la
motion tendance opposer la question
préalable Madame Raymonde ponce et les
membres du groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 1 tendant à
opposer la question préalable au texte
en discussion la parole est à Madame
Raymond ponce pour la motion pour 10
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
nous y voilà au troisième acte du plan
objectif plein d'emplois présenté par le
gouvernement en septembre dernier et qui
faisait de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et de la réforme des retraites
les deux premiers temps d'une politique
de l'emploi conduisant notamment à la
précarisation généralisée des
travailleurs du pays ce projet de loi
dit du plein emploi propose une réforme
complète du service public de l'emploi
sans qu'aucune étude ne vienne faire
d'état des lieux de la précédente fusion
ANPE Assedic et sans que le gouvernement
ne questionne ni les emplois vacants qui
cherchent frénétiquement à combler ni
l'état du travail en France 40 ans 40
ans de loi ciblées sur l'emploi avec un
seul point aveugle le travail l'état du
travail en France en signe le bilan car
ce que nous avions dit lors de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage que nous
avions inlassablement répété lors de la
réforme des retraites nous disons pour
cette loi le gouvernement maltraite le
monde du travail avec de multiples
réformes dans le seul but d'augmenter le
taux d'emploi sans s'attaquer à la
question primordiale du travail facteur
d'exposition au risque physique
exposition au risque chimiques intensité
du travail autonomie selon tous les
indicateurs les performances françaises
sont désastreuses y compris par rapport
à nos voisins européens
selon l'enquête européenne sur les
conditions de travail 34% des
travailleurs français souffrent de
postures douloureuses dans leur travail
22% en Allemagne 49% souffrent d'anxiété
au travail 30% en Europe 45% des
Français estiment être correctement
payés contre 58% des Européens et plus
des deux tiers des Allemands enfin 39%
estiment que leur santé est à risque du
fait de leur activité professionnelle
soit 6 points de plus que la moyenne des
travailleurs européens depuis 40 ans les
conditions de travail se dégradent selon
la Dares l'exposition à au moins trois
contraintes physiques concernent un
tiers des salariés en 2016 soit trois
fois plus quand
1984 les troubles psychologiques et
l'épuisement professionnel sont à
l'origine de 20% des arrêts
qu'importe ses alertes dans la droite
ligne des politiques d'activation des
chômeurs le gouvernement ne se préoccupe
que des centaines de milliers de postes
vacants sans jamais interroger les
causes de leur nom attractivité mais
vers lesquels ils tournent toute sa
politique d'orientation et de
contraintes des populations sans emploi
cette politique vise à réduire les
capacités de négociations des demandeurs
d'emploi et à promouvoir une société du
précaria une méta-analyse de 94 études
de l'Université de Cambridge publié
l'année dernière documente le sujet elle
conclut que si les sanctions améliorent
le taux de retour à l'emploi cette
amélioration s'effectue au détriment de
la qualité de l'emploi retrouvé au prix
d'externalités négatives comme
l'augmentation du non-recourt dû à l'eau
de chômage de la dégradation de la santé
des travailleurs de l'augmentation y
compris de la maltraitance infantile et
l'explosion de la pauvreté des
demandeurs d'emploi
avec 20 ans de retard
votre gouvernement copie des lois en
Allemagne qui avait réformé le service
public de l'emploi et établit une
jonction de celui-ci avec les structures
d'accompagnement des allocataires de
minima sociaux elle s'est accompagnée
comme vous d'une réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui diminuait la durée
d'indemnisation le bilan de ces
politiques agressive d'activation des
chômeurs valide les résultats de l'étude
de Cambridge certes les lois arts ont
créé 2,5 millions d'emplois mais comme
le souligne l'étude de la direction
générale du Trésor ses emplois
correspondent majoritairement à des
emplois à temps partiels des contrats
courts des contrats intérimaires de
sorte que le bilan des lois en Allemagne
s'est traduit par l'augmentation du taux
de pauvreté globale
des lois ARS ont amélioré la pariement
effectivement entre l'emploi et les
chômeurs mais au détriment de ces
derniers contraint et forcé d'accepter
des emplois dégradés et permettant aux
entreprises de multiplier les emplois
précaires de faibles productivité en
fermant ainsi des générations entières
et surtout les jeunes dans la précarité
ainsi le gouvernement impose une réforme
de précarisation des travailleurs en
connaissance de cause car il sait que
les 6% d'emploi vacants présentent un
défaut majeur d'attractivité les
employeurs concernés ne sont d'ailleurs
pas dupes puisque selon Pôle Emploi 75%
des employeurs reconnaissent que les
conditions de travail des postes
proposés découragent les candidats
l'adresse dans une étude sur les
conditions de travail et les difficultés
de recrutement indiquent je cite que
même quand l'employeur ne les évoque pas
explicitement les conditions de travail
demeurent significatement
significativement corréler aux problèmes
de recrutement face à cela le
gouvernement fin de découvrir que
l'accompagnement à l'emploi est
insuffisant sans évoquer le manque de
moyens des travailleurs sociaux et les
portefeuilles des conseillers
accompagnant quelquefois jusqu'à 1000
personnes or ce projet de loi ne propose
aucune fourchette pour les portefeuilles
et d'ailleurs la simple évocation de
ratio est frappée d'y recevabilité le
gouvernement peut bien regretter que 60%
d'allocataire ou RSA ne sont pas
inscrits à Pôle emploi car si ces
personnes ne sont pas inscrites en tant
que demandeur d'emploi c'est pour la
plupart parce qu'elles n'en sont pas là
dans leur parcours quant à ceux qui
effectuent des allers-retours dans le
dis positif c'est précisément parce
qu'elles sont majoritairement
prisonnières d'emploi précaires en CDD
en temps partiel ou en intérim vous
pouvez donc réformer une nouvelle fois
le service public de l'emploi privatisé
davantage multiplier les réformes
antisociales en imaginant que les
emplois vacants sont des trous et qu'il
faut contraindre les travailleurs à
déboucher on accélère ainsi le tourneur
le mouvement d'émission déjà en cours et
la précarité généralisée en définitive
le bilan des politiques que copie le
gouvernement des autres pays en disant
sur la société qu'elle annonce et la
rupture qui a l'accentue avec notre
modèle Républic de protection sociale
ces politiques dessinent une société qui
pour reprendre Anna Aaron
transforme les humains en animal laberon
prisonniers de métiers pénible et
précaires le monde du plein emploi selon
le gouvernement c'est un monde
productiviste alors que le dépassement
des limites planétaires nous invite
collectivement à revoir les politiques
sociales économiques c'est un monde du
travail dégradé alors que de plus en
plus les travailleurs se questionnent
sur le sens de leur travail et des
missions c'est un monde où qu'une
activité autre que celle de la
production marchande n'est prise en
compte alors même que l'urgence est à
une société du soin de l'entraide de la
solidarité contre cette société de plein
emploi des bullshites jobs nous
défendons le plein emploi solidaire pour
des emplois utiles sur les plans social
et environnemental via la garantie
d'emplois contre ce modèle productiviste
qui entraîne la planète entière dans la
catastrophe climatique nous défendons le
relatissement la baisse du temps de
travail et le partage des richesses
contre le workfair nous défendons
l'instauration des revenus minimum
garantis sans contrepartie car la
pauvreté la pauvreté la première trappe
à l'emploi ce qui rend inerte
l'opposition entre prestations et
travail et c'est le revenu qui insère et
l'effort d'insertion ne doit pas peser
uniquement sur les personnes précaires
mais d'abord sur les pouvoirs publics
car la pauvreté reste un phénomène
structurel qui convoque la
responsabilité de toute la société en
d'autres termes la réciprocité implique
d'abord une responsabilité collective de
solidarité envers les plus pauvres et
doit être confondu ni avec la logique
rétributive ni avec la logique
paternaliste et punitive qui aurions de
vos politiques sociales la politique de
l'emploi durable et solidaire doit
d'abord miser sur l'accompagnement à la
fois des entreprises en difficulté de
recrutement mais aussi des personnes à
fortiori lorsqu'elles sont dans des
situations sociales difficiles qui
requiert non pas des sanctions
de la défiance mais des politiques
d'insertion sociale sur la santé de
logement les transports ou la petite
enfance
comme pour les retraites où vous avez
renvoyé à plus tard le débat sur le
travail dans cette loi vous renvoyez à
plus tard l'analyse de la crise
d'attractivité des emplois les deux
sujets pourtant sont liés en trois lois
les questions de faux sont escamotées le
groupe écologiste conteste cette
inversion des priorités et vous propose
en conséquence de voter notre notre
question préalable je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
contre la motion ce Xavier pour 10
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur chers collègues la question
préalable que nous examinons cet
après-midi a été déposé par nos
collègues pour dénoncer je cite la
politique sociale mise en place par le
gouvernement
en effet vous dénoncez l'objectif de
plein emploi que nous soutenons depuis
le début du mandat car oui nous avons la
conviction que ce n'est pas que par le
travail que nous pourrons rééquilibrer
notre système social et par la même que
nous protégerons au mieux nos
concitoyens vous dénoncez ce texte comme
je cite poursuivant une logique
productiviste qui s'avérera destructrice
pour l'humain comme pour la nature mais
ma chère collègue grâce aux effets de
notre politique 337 000 emplois ont été
créés en 2022 soit l'équivalent de 5
milliards d'euros de recettes
supplémentaires pour la sécurité sociale
comment pensez-vous concevoir un système
social redistributif avec un modèle
économique décroissant comment
établissez-vous un pacte social solide
sans la reconnaissance de la valeur
travail nous sommes en effet convaincus
que le travail est le facteur d'égalité
sociale que c'est par le travail que les
individus trouvent leur place dans la
société et consente à la redistribution
de la richesse
dans cette période de tension sociale
très forte nous pensons que l'un des
facteurs d'apaisement consistera dans
une meilleure intégration de nos
concitoyens au sein de notre système
social en effet mes chers collègues
l'une des fractures de notre pays réside
bien entre ceux qui pensent pleinement
intégrés au sein de notre modèle social
et ceux qui s'en sentent exclus ce
modèle a été fragilisé par la montée des
individualités par le repli sur soi et
la peur de l'autre conséquence néfastes
des crises que nous traversons la pierre
angulaire du rétablissement de ce pacte
social consistera en la réintégration du
travail au centre de notre de notre
édifice le ferment de division se situe
dans la croyance que certains
travaillent pour les autres et que
certaines et certains se sentent
totalement exclus de notre système
social
chers collègues c'est en construisant un
pacte clair précis renforcé et
intégrative que nos concitoyens pourront
adhérer vous dénoncez la logique
gouvernementale de faire travailler tout
le monde mais oui madame la sénatrice
nous assumons pleinement de placer le
travail au cœur de notre modèle social
ce projet de loi que nous examinons cet
après-midi permet au marché du travail
d'inclure pleinement les plus éloignés
de l'emploi pour que le chômage ne soit
plus une fatalité en effet 18% des
allocataires du RSA ne sont pas orientés
vers un organisme d'accompagnement et
16% sont encore inscrits plus de 10 ans
après leur premier inscription nous ne
pouvons pas nous ne pouvons
pas constater ces chiffres et ne pas
agir contrairement à la politique que
vous défendez nous ne pensons pas que le
maintien au RSA soit une solution
pérenne pour nos concitoyens la société
n'est pas kite lorsqu'elle donne 600
euros à des allocataires nous croyons
que le travail amène à l'indépendance et
à la sortie de l'exclusion sociale
ce texte permettra également un meilleur
accompagnement pour les travailleurs en
situation de handicap dont l'orientation
professionnelle l'accès aux droits et
les conditions de travail seront
renforcées loin d'être un texte de
recentralisation comme certains membres
de cette hémicycle revendique il
permettra également avec son article 10
de confier à la commune la qualité
d'autorité organisatrice du jeune enfant
et de préciser les modalités de
transfert à des sons intercommunale
ainsi pour toutes ces raisons et parce
que nous souhaitons lutter contre les
inégalités de naissance les égalités de
destin notre groupe votera pour
contredans cette question préalable et
souhaite que nous ayons différents
échanges au sein de cette hémicycle sur
ce texte je vous remercie c'est veiller
à ne pas vous tromper tout à l'heure
dans le scrutin public parce que je
voudrais pas que vous soyez tous obligé
de faire des corrections de vote
bien comme je l'ai dit pour la première
motion nous avons d'abord la vie de la
Commission et préparez-vous quand même
pour le scrutin public merci
merci monsieur le Président alors bien
entendu on va mettre un évier un avis
pardon défavorable à cette motion nous
partageons complètement en fait
l'objectif de ce texte pour un meilleur
accompagnement et amener les personnes
vers l'emploi aujourd'hui le taux de
chômage est arrivé à un niveau assez bas
mais en revanche il reste encore
beaucoup de personnes qui sont éloignées
de l'emploi et pour ces personnes il
faut un accompagnement certainement plus
fort et des partenariats qui seront
trouvés justement dans le cadre de cette
nouvelle organisation donc pour nous il
n'y a pas de pas de question je pense
aussi parce que je vous ai entendu sur
les conditions de travail etc moi
franchement quand je vous entends je me
dis si j'ai 18 ans ça c'est sûr je vais
pas aller travailler tellement ça doit
être horrible de travailler en France et
que peut-être c'est beaucoup mieux en
Allemagne quoi que vous avez dit ça
mieux en Allemagne au début puis après
moins bien après donc on sait pas trop
finalement où on va aller en tout cas
sur aussi sur les conditions de travail
les les taux concernant les
reconnaissances en fait de difficultés
moi je peux vous dire je suis allé au
Danemark il y a avec la Commission et
j'avais été très étonné parce que dans
ce pays du bonheur finalement ils
étaient au même niveau que nous sur les
risques psychosociaux donc il y a
d'autres causes donc je pense que il
faut y travailler je crois que les
entreprises aussi il faut leur faire
confiance elles améliorent beaucoup et
moi je connais beaucoup en fait de chefs
d'entreprise alors effectivement c'est
pas celle du CAC 40 moi celle que je
rencontre c'est des très petites
entreprises petites entreprises moyennes
entreprises et celle là elles font
beaucoup d'efforts et à tous niveaux
justement parce qu'elles sont attachées
à leur personnel et qu'elles n'ont pas
envie de les voir partir et surtout de
les voir partir aussi en mauvaise santé
donc je crois sincèrement que pour
toutes ces raisons le texte on doit on
doit encore l'améliorer certainement
mais en tout cas bien entendu on rejette
cette motion
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame le
rapporteur et Monsieur Covelli on dit
l'essentiel donc la vie est défavorable
pour les raisons évoquées j'ajoute
simplement deux points le premier pour
dire que contrairement à ce que madame
la sénatrice pensait manger a évoqué il
n'y a pas de précarisation avec la
création de l'emploi d'emploi depuis
2017 au contraire au cours de l'année
2022 nous avons assisté à une bascule
statistique qui est intéressante et qui
je crois peut satisfaire tout le monde
dans les indicateurs de l'INSEE sur les
créations d'emplois il apparaît que pour
tous les contrats de 1 mois et plus et
c'est un indicateur qui a toujours été
utilisé nous sommes passés à 52% de CDI
dans les premiers dans les contrats
signés de 2010 à 2019 nous étions entre
43 et 47% de CDI dans la masse des
embauches nous sommes passés à 52% c'est
la démonstration qu'il n'y a pas la
précarisation que vous avez évoquée dans
les créations d'emplois qui sont
affichées qui atteignent un million 7 en
socle sans compter les 80000 qui ont été
créés au cours du premier trimestre 2023
la deuxième chose mais madame la
rapporteur et monsieur le sénateur l'ont
dit je pense que nous pouvons continuer
à gérer vont continuer à améliorer la
situation et qui a une forme de fatalité
ou de fatalisme qui peut trans qui
peuvent transparaître dans certains de
vos propos que nous ne partageons pas
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
pensons que les mesures nous proposons
seront utiles pour le Pôle emploi
merci nous passons au scrutin public sur
la question préalable
je vous rappelle que la vie de la
commission est défavorable avec du
Gouvernement est défavorable le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
dans 343 exprimé 279 pour 27 contre 252
la motion n'est pas adoptée dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier non pour
le groupe Union centriste pour 8 minutes
la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la Présidente de
commission madame la rapporteur chers
collègues je veux tout d'abord saluer le
travail de la commission des affaires
sociales de sa présidence de notre
collègue rapporteur madame la
vice-présidente Pascal Gruny avoir un
mot pour Catherine de roche parce que
c'est la dernière fois qu'elle siège sur
ce banc en tant que présidente de
commission lui dire tout simplement que
ça a été pas le dernier jour mais pour
le dernier texte c'était un plaisir de
travailler avec elle et que c'est une
grande présence de commission
remercier Pascal Gruny pour son
investissement sur ce texte pendant que
d'autres compte tenu des échéances avait
moins de disponibilités et bien elle a
fait un travail remarquable voilà mes
chers collègues ce texte ça intervient
dans un contexte où notre pays a besoin
d'apaisement de calme et de confiance
sur la confiance justement le groupe UC
du Sénat et je crois la majorité c'est
d'artorial ne seront jamais du côté que
celles et ceux qui défendent la
verticalité et qui pensent au fond de
même qu'une gestion du service public
par la haute administration est toujours
plus performante que gestion au plus
près du terrain par les élus locaux et
territoriaux ou par une gestion
paritaire la défense des corps
intermédiaires l'attachement au
paritarisme au dialogue social et la
gestion plus près du terrain par des
élus reste notre cap en toute
circonstance à ce propos nous voulons
aussi saluer le remarquable travail
d'émissions locales et le réseau des
maisons de l'emploi nous vous avons
écouté messieurs les ministres vous nous
avez rassuré mais nous resterons très
vigilants sur ces questions revenons sur
le projet de loi il entend rénover la
gouvernance du service public de
l'emploi et de l'insertion partant du
constat que le suivi et l'accompagnement
des personnes rencontreront des
difficultés sociales et professionnelles
sont insuffisamment coordonnées le défi
du plein emploi est finalement moins une
question d'offre d'emploi aujourd'hui
produit que ou de dynamique économique
un défi d'adaptation au monde du travail
ou d'incitation au travail et pour nous
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais disons-le
aussi dans l'incitation de travail il y
a aussi la nécessité de faire en sorte
que le travail paye mieux le travail
doit mieux payer il est vrai que les
personnes sans emploi sont inégalement
accompagnés dans leur insertion
professionnelle pour ceux qui concerne
les allocataires du RSA 60% des
bénéficiaires ne disposent pas de
contrat d'accompagnement et seulement
41% d'entre eux sont inscrits à Pôle
Emploi chiffres terribles insatisfaisant
inacceptable mais qu'on ne nous fasse
pas le coup de montrer les départements
du doigt ils agissent avec efficacité en
fonction des moyens dont ils disposent
reste qu'il y a une occasion à saisir au
moment où le marché de l'emploi étendu
et où les opportunités sont nombreuses y
compris pour les personnes éloignées
depuis très longtemps du marché du
travail
ce défi pour notre pays avec notamment
les trois voies de formation
l'information initiale l'information
continue mais aussi la VAE la
valorisation des acquis de l'expérience
il s'agit donc de mieux articuler les
parcours d'insertion et d'agir pour que
les actions soient plus en adéquation
avec les besoins du marché de l'emploi
le projet de loi ont également levé l'un
des principaux freins à l'emploi la
garde d'enfant en tentant d'améliorer la
gouvernance de la politique d'accueil du
jeune enfant pour cela il conviendrait
qu'une offre fournie en mode de garde
formelle soit accessible aux parents et
ce n'est malheureusement pas toujours le
cas la capacité théorique dans les modes
d'accueil formel a même décrue de 2014 à
2020 et la pénurie de professionnels
vient réduire encore l'offre disponible
ce qui inquiète nombre de maires est une
grave question et pose aussi des
problèmes à de nombreuses familles mais
revenons au réseau France travail mes
chers collègues l'article 4 appelle
la création ce réseau aurait pour
mission d'accueillir d'orienter
d'accompagner de former d'insérer les
personnes à la recherche d'un emploi ou
rencontrant des difficultés sociales et
professionnelles le groupe UC tient à
saluer l'amendement de Pascal gruni pour
que Pôle emploi ne devienne pas
l'opérateur France travaille la
perspective de ce changement d'identité
est une source d'inquiétude pour les
acteurs de l'emploi pour les personnes
inscrites à Pôle emploi et pour les
acteurs du service public mais si Pôle
Emploi joue un rôle clé au sein du
service public de l'emploi et nous
sommes souhaitables qu'il se nomment
nous ne pensons pas qu'il soit
souhaitable qu'il se nomme France
travail cela créerait inévitablement de
la confusion et même peut-être une forme
de hiérarchisation dont nous ne voulons
pas de plus il nous paraît nécessaire
d'ajouter à ces missions celle de
répondre aux besoins des employeurs en
matière de recrutement de mise en
relation entre les offres et les
demandes d'emploi et d'information sur
la situation du marché du travail afin
de donner de la visibilité aux acteurs
je vous proposerai que le comité
national puisse identifier le besoin de
financement dans un cadre pluri annuel
la coordination des acteurs et
l'harmonisation des pratiques ne saurait
se transformer en un cadre contraignant
et uniforme que l'État imposerait aux
collectivités aux acteurs locaux chaque
acteur doit pouvoir préserver ses
prérogatives et développer des solutions
adaptées aux besoins des territoires et
des bassins d'emploi les moyens
financiers pour la mise en oeuvre
devront suivre or le texte est un peu
muet sur ce point nous saluons un autre
amendement pour que les critères
d'orientation d'une demandeur d'emploi
vers l'organisme référent chargé
d'assurer son tac campagnement soit
défini par le collectivité territorial
l'État et les partenaires sociaux dans
le cadre du Comité National France
travail puis approuvé par le ministre
plutôt qu'il soit fixé par arrêté
ministériel après un simple avis du
comité national nous saluons également
la décision de la commission des
affaires sociales de supprimer la charte
d'engagement les collectivités
territoriales disposent de compétences
propres en matière d'emploi et d'ins au
titre desquelles elles ont vocations
dans tous les cas à prendre part aux
instances de gouvernance sans avoir à
signer une charte d'engagement rappelons
l'objectif principal de ce texte de
poser le cadre commun d'un
accompagnement plus intensif des
demandeurs d'emploi avec l'objectif
affiché que les personnes éloignées de
l'emploi notamment les bénéficiaires du
RSA s'engage sur une durée hebdomadaire
de case à 20h d'activités accompagnées
sur le modèle du contrat d'engagement
jeune et là l'article 2 ne traduit pas
l'objectif pourtant essentiel de
garantir un accompagnement plus intensif
et de mobiliser les personnes éloignées
de l'emploi pendant une durée
hebdomadaire prédéfinie en matière de
sanction des bénéficiaires du RSA nous
considérons que le président du conseil
départemental est le seul compétent pour
prendre la décision je salue
l'amendement de Pascal grunis qui infime
clairement nos départements ont en effet
à mes chers collègues une expérience
en matière de RSA concernant l'article
10 et la politique d'accueil du jeune
enfant nous considérons qu'il est
contradictoires de vouloir confier aux
communes davantage de prérogatives et
d'encadrer l'action des collectivités
territoriales par une stratégie prise
par arrêter ministériel par ailleurs des
objectifs de développement de l'offre
d'accueil sont déjà fixés dans la coche
ETAC nous rejoignons la rapporteur une
fois de plus sur la demande de
suppression de la procédure selon
laquelle le préfet pourra en cas de
manquement d'une commune demandée à la
cave d'élaborer à sa place son schéma
communal est de mettre en place un
projet de création de relais petite
enfance il n'est pas souhaitable de
confier aux communes de nouvelles
compétences en les assortissant d'une
forme de contrôle renforcée nous pouvons
faire confiance aux communes pour
répondre aux fortes attentes des
familles dès lors qu'elles ont la
capacité à le faire et surtout les
moyens financiers indispensables sous
ces réserves le groupe UC votre a
favorablement ce projet de loi amendée
car il répond à des constats et à des
préoccupations que nous partageons même
si des inconnus demeurent quant au moyen
mis en oeuvre et la confiance que vous
abstez au collectivités territoriales je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est maintenant Madame Véronique
Guillotin pour le groupe RDSE pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la Présidente de
commission madame la rapporteur chers
collègues alors que nous débattillons de
la difficile réforme des retraites en
début d'année le travail a fait l'objet
de débat souvent flammé au sein et en
dehors du Parlement des débats sur le
temps de travail sur l'équilibre entre
vie personnelle et vie professionnelle
sur la sécurité la qualité de vie au
travail des débats philosophiques
parfois certains revendiquant le droit à
la paresse d'autres et je m'y inclus
considérant le travail comme une forme
d'émancipation et l'assurance d'un
avenir de progrès et de croissance la
réalité du marché du travail avec ces
370 000 emplois vacants malgré 6
millions de chômeurs ne pourra pas nous
exempter d'un vrai débat sur l'avenir du
travail les tensions de recrutement dans
les secteurs sensibles et les
aspirations des nouvelles générations
sont à prendre en considération
en attendant un projet de loi dédié
celui-ci vise à rénover la gouvernance
du service public de l'emploi et de
l'insertion pour tenter de mieux faire
converger l’offre et la demande et
permettre la création de 700 000 emplois
l'objectif est d'atteindre le plein
emploi c'est-à-dire un taux de chômage
inférieur à 5 %
considérant à juste titre que l'offre
trop éclatée et insuffisamment
coordonnée le réseau France travail va
être créé fédérant ainsi les principaux
acteurs que sont l'État les
collectivités et les opérateurs
l'objectif de ce réseau sera
d'accueillir orienté accompagné formé
insérer les personnes en recherche
d'emploi ou rencontrant des difficultés
sociales et professionnelles il sera
piloté par les comités France travail à
tous les échelons pour coordonner les
acteurs et animer les politiques de
l'emploi et d'insertion au plus près des
territoires les notions de proximité et
de coordination des acteurs sans que
soit remis en question leurs compétences
vont dans le bon sens nous serons
attentifs à ce que cette réforme
n'aboutissent pas à recentraliser une
politique indissentiable de l'engagement
des collectivités et des opérateurs et
de leur précieuses connaissances du
terrain en plus des amendements que nous
défendrons dans ce sens nous soutenons
l'essentiel des modifications faites en
commission sur cette partie mais nous ne
nous crisperons pas sur la dénomination
et seront surtout vigilants sur le fond
toutes les personnes sans emploi seront
désormais automatiquement inscrites sur
la liste des demandeurs d'emploi et
orientés vers un accompagnement
professionnel ou social avec l'organisme
le plus adapté à leur situation nous
saluons cette lisibilité ainsi que la
logique de droit et de devoir unifier
pour les personnes sans emploi comme
pour tous les acteurs de ce service
public un contrat d'engagement un
contrat engagera le demandeur d'emploi
et son organisme référent dans un plan
d'action avec des objectifs d'insertion
sociale et professionnelle en cas de
non-respects de ce contrat le texte
prévoit comme pour les allocations
chômage la possibilité de suspendre le
versement du RSA favorable à la notion
de droits et devoirs je salue la
possibilité plus de régularisation
rétroactive si le bénéficiaire respecte
à nouveau ses engagements ce texte
introduit également le conditionnement
de la location à des activités
hebdomadaires accompagnées sur ce sujet
je souscris à deux principes que la
notion d'activité soit envisagée de
manière large en fonction de la
situation des capacités de chacun et des
besoins du territoire enfin que les 14
heures hebdomadaires demeurent un
objectif à atteindre l'inscription de 14
heures minimale par la commission
d'affaires sociales nous apparaît peu
réalistes quelquefois voire peu
opportunes certaines personnes sont très
éloignées de l'emploi certains
bénéficiaires du RSA sont sans abri avec
un état de santé dégradé pour eux la
marche et haute et la loi doit fixer un
cadre juste contraignant pour ceux qui
pourraient mais ne font pas et adapter
pour ceux qui voudraient mais ne peuvent
pas concernant la formation
professionnelle connaissant l'engagement
des régions sur ce sujet je défendrai
une position qui les conforte dans leur
rôle pivot concernant les travailleurs
handicapés les évolutions proposées
attendues par les
vont dans le bon sens je pense par
exemple au droit des travailleurs en
ESAT qui convergent enfin vers le droit
des salariés le dernier article du
projet vise à renforcer l'accueil des
jeunes enfants qui est l'un des
principaux freins parmi d'autres mais
principal quand même principe frein du
retour à l'emploi les communes
deviendront ainsi autorité
organisatrices nous y sommes favorables
sous réserve cela a été dit par les
prédécesseurs d'un accompagnement à la
hauteur ce que à quoi monsieur le
ministre vous vous êtes engagé je tenais
ici à rappeler que l'objectif des 200
000 nouvelles places de crèches fixe un
cap ambitieux l'objectif qualitatif est
important mais reste indissociable de
deux éléments que sont la qualité de
l'accueil et la revalorisation des
métiers en effet dix mille postes en
crèche sont aujourd'hui vacants mettant
en difficulté à la fois les parents mais
aussi les professionnels restants nous
serons donc attentifs au monodalité de
mise en œuvre de cette réforme
importante pour notre pays je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Philippe mouillé
pour le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la commission efface
sociale que je salue pour cette dernière
président ici en séance madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues nous
sommes aujourd'hui réunis pour examiner
un texte qui a pour objectif d'atteindre
le plein emploi en coordonnant mieux les
acteurs du service public de l'emploi et
en renforçant l'accompagnement des
personnes qui sont les plus joignées de
l'emploi je pense notamment bénéficiaire
du RSA et aux personnes en situation de
handicap nous partageons le constat que
ceux qui restent aujourd'hui sans emploi
malgré la baisse du chômage et des
milliers d'emplois pourvus ont besoin
d'un accompagnement personnalisé sur
mesure pour y parvenir le gouvernement
propose donc entre autres de transformer
les services publics de l'emploi de
l'insertion
si je cellule intention je regrette
toutefois que le projet initial soit sur
ce point trop centralisateur c'est
pourquoi je tiens à remercier Madame la
rapporteur parce qu'elle Grigny d'avoir
fait adopter en commission de nombreux
amendements en réponse aux inquiétudes
exprimées par les élus territoriaux qui
ainsi conserveront leur prérogative et
seront pleinement impliqués dans le
nouveau dispositif
je concentrer mon intervention sur les
titres 3 qui vise améliorer les
conditions d'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap rappelons que le
taux de chômage de ces personnes et de
l'ordre de 14% contre une moyenne
nationale de 7,3%. les mesures proposées
ont pour objectif d'une part de
favoriser l'accès à l'emploi et d'autre
part d'améliorer les droits sociaux des
travailleurs handicapés en milieu
protégés ces avancées étaient attendues
par les associations repentatives des
personnes en situation de handicap et
nous les soutenons
le projet de loi prévoit l'article 8 que
les droits associés à la reconnaissance
de la qualité de travailleurs handicapés
soit étendu à toutes les catégories de
bénéficiaires de l'OTH un autre
initiative au sein de la commission
sociale ces dispositions ont été
complétées par l'adoption de deux
amendements importants l'invisant
inclure parmi les bénéficiaires de l'ETH
les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans et les
étudiants ne bénéficier pas d'une RQTH
mais dispositions de la diagnostiquation
d'une décision favorable de la cDPH
l'autre a établi à la possibilité d'une
modulation des contributions des
employeurs de l'Agefiph en tenant compte
de la reconnaissance de la lourdeur du
handicap cette dispositions étaient
supprimées lors de la réforme de l'ETH
autre avancée forte la suppression de
l'orientation en milieu ordinaire du
travail chacun est présumé pouvoir
travailler en milieu ordinaire ce même
article 8 prévoit que le dispositif de
l'emploi accompagné demeure sous le
pilotage de l'État qui ouvre à d'autres
acteurs que ceux du médico-social
le projet de loi d'ailleurs pérennise
deux expérimentations qui sont de nature
à favoriser le passage de l'entreprise
adaptée à l'entreprise ordinaire je vais
citer bien entendu le CDD tremplin et
également la pérennisation des
Entreprises Adaptées de temps de travail
temporaire
de plus le texte du Gouvernement propose
d'aligner des droits des travailleurs
accueillis en ESAT sur ce reconnu aux
salariés par le Code du travail il
s'agit là d'une avancée majeure séduit
par tous de nouveaux droits individuels
et collectifs sont ainsi reconnus à
juste titre au 120000 travailleurs
handicapés ainsi le projet de loi
prévoit d'octroyer une complémentaire
sont obligatoire des chèques-vacances
des tickets restaurants la prise en
charge des frais de mobilité et surtout
des droits collectifs tels que le droit
de grève ou le droit d'être syndiqué le
droit d'alerte ou de retrait ces mesures
rapprochent finalement les statues tout
en citant ces mesures nous étonnons que
leur traduction dans la loi devance la
fin des travaux actuellement menés sur
la transformation des esats de nouveau
nous avons un calendrier assez étonnant
de plus aucun soutien financier des
esats pour mettre en place ces nouveaux
droits n'est prévu dans le texte
d'ailleurs peu de chiffres sont contenus
dans le texte concernant les mesures
financières le modèle économique des
esats reste fragile sans être de l'État
beaucoup nous pourront pas suivre
financièrement
enfin lors de l'examen de ce projet de
loi monsieur le ministre une
problématique a été identifiée et reste
à résoudre concernant notamment les
titulaires de l'allocation adulte
handicapé en effet dès lors qu'un
travailleur handicapé bénéficiaire de
l'âge 2 travail plus de 17h30 par
semaine ils perdent la totalité de son
allocation il n'y a pas d'agressivité
cette disposition n'est certainement pas
de nature à les encourager à trouver
finalement un travail et cette question
peut peut-être également poser pour les
titulaires de prime d'invalidité
j'en appelle donc au gouvernement pour
prendre des mesures qui s'imposent pour
mettre fin à cette incohérence qui
devrait être finalement intérêt dans ce
texte je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Daniel
Chassin pour le groupe les indépendants
pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame
l'emporter mes chers collègues
en six ans le trop de chômage dans notre
pays est passé de 9,4 à 7,1 si l'on doit
de reconnaître le chemin parcouru la
bataille du plein emploi n'est encore
pas gagné c'est justement l'objectif
poursuivi par ce projet de loi qui vise
les personnes les plus alignées
l'éloignés du travail et notamment les
bénéficiaires de RSA mais pas seulement
le travail est l'une des valeurs
fondamentales de toute société c'est une
source d'épanouissement de l'individu
qui le valorise au sein de la famille au
sein de la société mais aussi dans sa
propre image c'est notamment le travail
qui insère au mieux les gens dans la
société ce projet de loi ne sigmatise
pas les bénéficiaires du RSA comme je
l'ai entendu
mais au contraire apporte une
valorisation des bénéficiaires de
récents leur offrant un accompagnement
en leur permettant de sortir de la
catégorie d'allocataires d'aide sociale
je rappelle que sur les 2 millions
d'inscrits horaires
seul 40% sont aujourd'hui inscrits à
Pôle emploi il nous faut donc aller
chercher les 60% restants les
accompagner au mieux cela veut dire leur
proposer un abonnement m'accompagnement
personnalisé et adapté leur situation
car on sait bien que beaucoup de
bénéficiaires du RSA ne pourront pas
retrouver immédiatement vers l'emploi
juste parce qu'il sera il serait
désormais automatiquement inscrit à
France travail beaucoup devront d'abord
bénéficier d'un accompagnement
d'insertion sociale et Monsieur le
Ministre cela demandera des moyens
supplémentaires pour un succès les
financements de l'État devront augmenter
les conseils départementaux ne pourront
pas augmenter leur budget
notre proposition d'amendement reprenant
la PPL du président maluré et visant à
permettre le cumul pendant 9 mois du RSA
et de revenus salariés nous semblait
être une solution efficace pour le
retour vers l'emploi l'article 2 prévoit
toutes les étapes de l'orientation et de
l'accompagnement la prise en compte des
difficultés particulières en matière de
logement et de santé ou de gamme
d'enfants nous regrettons que le type
d'activité hebdomadaire pouvant faire
l'objet du contrat d'engagement ne
figure pas dans le texte du Gouvernement
car cette omission a pu laisser penser à
certains qu'il s'agirait du travail
gratuit or il s'agira bien d'un plan
d'action pour favoriser le retour à
l'emploi par exemple en découvrant le
milieu professionnel une formation
progressive ferme si du bénévolat ou
même en prenant soin de sa santé lorsque
celle-ci constitue un frein vers
l'emploi j'ai déposé un amendement dans
ce sens plus largement réorganiser tous
les acteurs de l'accompagnement grand un
grand réseau
représentera un gain de temps et
d'efficacité nous saluons l'adoption par
la commission d'un amendement précisant
la mission d'appui du réseau France
travail vers les entreprises en matière
de recrutement et la prise en compte du
marché du travail monsieur le ministre
l'émission locale comme d'autres
facteurs spécialisés 5 quêtes fortement
de cette réorganisation et d'une remise
en cause de leur expertise propre en
matière d'accompagnement il est
essentiel de maintenir leur compétences
envers le public et qu'elle vienne en
aide et j'ai déposé plusieurs
amendements visant notamment à assurer
leur pérennité leur autonomie ainsi que
leur contribution dans l'élaboration des
orientations nationales ce projet de loi
ne
laisse ne s'adresse pas uniquement aux
bénéficiaires du RSA il concerne aussi
avec les articles 8 9 les personnes en
situation de handicap avec pour objectif
de faciliter leur insertion
professionnelle en milieu ordinaire et
sur laquelle France travaille pourra
émettre des
propositions il est temps certains
doigts individuels et collectifs aux
salariés et aux travailleurs des esats
et assouplis les dispositions relatives
aux Entreprises Adaptées de travail
temporaire chez d'épouser plusieurs
amendements qui visent à aller plus loin
en faveur de ces entreprises
enfin le texte par l'article 10 traite
aussi l'un des freins majeurs à la
recherche d'emploi celui de la garde
d'enfants sur lequel les communes seront
des acteurs clés qui nécessitera aussi
des mesures de compensation à la hauteur
de leur nouvelle compétences l'ensemble
de ce texte porte des mesures qui vont
dans le bon sens en faveur de l'emploi
et en faveur de meilleur accompagnement
des personnes qui en sont éloignées bien
sûr toutes ces mesures ne vaudront que
si les moyens que si les moyens de
meilleurs accompagnement sont
effectivement déployés et nous devrons
éveiller lors du prochain budget le
groupe Les Indépendants soutient
l'esprit de ce projet de loi
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Raymond ponce pour le
groupe écologiste pour 5 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministre chers collègues à peine les
expérimentations des marques que le
Gouvernement présente le projet de
réforme France travail qui comme pour la
loi retraite escamote la question du
travail donc en fait France emploi n'a
qu'une finalité le plein emploi à 5 % de
chômage qui permettra effectivement de
baisser les allocations chômage comme
prévu dans la réforme et ainsi avec la
loi retraite la boucle de l'attaque
contre le monde du travail se refermera
ce sont les mêmes chantiers que ceux de
Laurent Wauquiez sous Monsieur Sarkozy
je les rappelle hein la réforme de
l'assurance chômage de un plan pour
l'emploi des seigneurs 3 le nouveau
service public de l'emploi en lançant
Pôle Emploi
issu de la fusion de l'ANPE et de
l'Assedic et Monsieur veuquier
d'affirmer cette promesse je le cite
nous constituerons d'ici trois ans le
service public de l'emploi le plus
performant d'Europe
c'est la même doctrine des économistes
libéraux de l'emploi mais avec quel
bilan le résultat de la fusion ce sont
17 suicides d'origine professionnelle ce
sont des effectifs qui se maintiennent à
56 000 agents en 2022 alors que
l'Allemagne modèle pourtant de cette
réforme dispose du double pour son
service public de l'emploi le résultat
ce sont des portefeuilles
surdimensionnés de sorte que selon le
rapport de la mission flash de
l'Assemblée nationale sur Pôle emploi en
2019 les agents ont appris à vivre avec
la pénurie d'effectifs seul augmente les
effectifs des personnes chargées des
contrôles alors là ça passe de 200 lors
de la fusion à 1000 en 2020 ce qui en
dit long sur les priorités du service
désormais de l'emploi
ce projet de loi ne fait d'ailleurs pas
exception puisqu'il accroît les pouvoirs
de sanction de l'opérateur France
travail les premiers articles
s'inscrivent dans ce processus à partir
d'un diagnostic
erroné car si comme le déplore le
gouvernement c'est 60% des allocataires
du RSA ne sont pas inscrits à Pôle
emploi c'est d'abord parce que 40% de
ceux qui sont dans cet halo de chômage
ont des problèmes de santé et c'est
aussi parce qu'un allocataire du RSA sur
4 étant difficulté vis-à-vis du logement
en conséquence pour ces allocataires la
première étape du parcours demeure celle
de l'inclusion sociale rendue difficile
par le décrochage de la location RSA du
seuil de pauvreté
et désormais un tiers des actions
d'accompagnement vise l'accès aux soins
un cinquième le soutien familial et la
garde d'enfants et 13% l'accès au
logement
ces problèmes sociaux réclament des
politiques sociales ambitieuses pour
lever des freins à l'emploi et non une
politique de sanction et de contrôle qui
ne feront comme l'ont démontré les
chercheurs l'ortie le gaz et
s'arrêteront qu'augmenter le non recours
nous documentons madame la rapporteur
nos analyses par des études et des
statistiques que vous vous obstinez
ignorer ce n'est pas mon avis se donne
je l'appuie sur des études et des
statistiques à l'inverse ce que France
travaille prépare avec ses dispositions
c'est une amplification de la
précarisation en forçant les personnes
les plus en difficulté à occuper les
emplois les plus difficiles et les moins
intractifs c'est aussi un risque de mise
sous tutelle quand même des missions
locales lesquelles des fonds d'un modèle
d'accompagnement complet du public jeune
y compris au moment de la garantie zone
et que le gouvernement a mis en
concurrence avec Pôle emploi via le
contrat engagement jeune contraint qu'il
prétend généraliser pour tous en un
contrat d'engagement unique
son syndicat dans les comités
territoriaux et locaux ont qu'au
président s'imposait pour les
départements et les régions ce que la
gouvernance France travaille instaure en
définitive c'est un écrasement des
discours alternatifs une des possession
progressive des collectivités de leur
compétences en matière d'accompagnement
social et de formation derrière les
critères d'orientation les référentiels
et les systèmes communs conçus par
l'opérateur France travail ce profil
l'uniformisation de l'accompagnement
vers le chrétien unique du retour à
l'emploi coûte que coûte quel que soit
la qualité de l'emploi et faisant fi des
activités que les allocataires du RSA
effectuent en faveur de leur famille de
leur quartier ou tout simplement les
activités pour survivre soit comme
l'exprime et ça va être l'objet d'un
rapport c'est un boulot de dingue de
vivre avec le RSA en retournant un
boulot de dingue le stigmate
présidentiel sur un pognon de dingue et
enfin rien dans le projet
la qualité des emplois les écologistes
refusent une société du plein emploi
dégradée et répressif alors où les
urgences sociales et climatiques
appellent un modèle basé sur
l'accompagnement globale et renforcée
comme à une bifurcation écologique en
mesure de faire advenir des emplois
utiles pour répondre aux besoins sociaux
et environnementaux et un plein emploi
solidaire loin de ce projet de
précarisation des plus fragiles le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
votera contre ce projet de loi merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Xavier pour le groupe RDPI pour
6 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues s'il y a bien
un combat mené par le Président de la
République mené de front et réussi c'est
bien celui du travail en 6 ans grâce aux
réformes menées c'est 1,700 millions
d'emplois un million pardon 700 000
emplois créés alors qu'hier ma
génération avait appris à vivre avec un
chômage systémique aujourd'hui la courbe
s'est inversée le taux de chômage a
atteint son plus bas niveau depuis 40
ans passant de 9,5 à 7,1 et le taux
d'emploi est à son plus haut niveau avec
52% des postes créés en CDI non le
chômage de masse n'est pas une fatalité
l'une des conséquences directes de notre
bonne dynamique économique et de la
forte création d'emplois c'est la
tension qui pèse sur notre vivier de
talent les entreprises connaissent
encore de réelles difficultés pour
embaucher les deux tiers des PME font
face à des problématiques de recrutement
et 60% des entreprises industrielles
disent renoncer à des opportunités de
croissance pour des raisons liées aux
mêmes difficultés
mais ces résultats nous montrent bien
une chose c'est que le plein emploi est
à portée de main et que personne n'est
in employable la majorité présidentielle
c'est donc fixer un objectif exigeant
mais de l'ordre du possible atteindre ce
plein emploi d'ici la fin du quinquennat
pour cela il nous faudra baisser encore
le taux de chômage à 5 % et donc créé au
moins 700 000 nouveaux emplois pour les
quatre prochaines années c'est donc dans
cet esprit que le gouvernement nous a
fait nous a présenté ce projet de loi en
prenant en compte trois axes sur
lesquels travailler d'une part les
besoins des entreprises en adéquation
avec les compétences des demandeurs
d'emploi je pense notamment au travail
collectif et aux actions menées depuis
2018 avec les régions sur le plan
d'investissement pour les compétences
le deuxième mais aussi les règles
relatives au marché du travail aux
indemnisations de l'assurance chômage
les réformes de 2019 et 2022 ont apporté
des réponses satisfaisantes mais il nous
faut aller plus loin enfin ce texte
entend apporter des réponses fortes sur
les services publics de l'emploi et son
fonctionnement il ne s'agit pas ici
comme le ministre de travail la rappeler
à plusieurs reprises de changer ce qui
marche bien je pense notamment aux
missions locales auprès des jeunes mais
bien d'améliorer la structure et la
gouvernance du service public de
l'emploi ainsi la transformation de Pôle
emploi en France en France travaille
permettrait ce maintien du statut
d'opérateur avec un rôle de coordination
au service des acteurs de l'emploi
renforcé et il ne s'agit pas ici non
plus de parler de recentralisation mais
bien d'un rôle de soutien technique
d'animateurs opérationnels qui
pourraient jouer demain que pourrait
France travail demain dans le cadre
d'une gouvernance très partagée avec les
élus locaux et les collectivités
c'est ici la principale nouveauté et
c'est aussi mes chers collègues la
possibilité de mettre en avant nos
territoires nous avons besoin d'une
transformation du service public de
l'emploi avec une gouvernance mieux
coordonnée et adaptée au territoire qui
permettrait le rapprochement de l'état
des régions et des départements avec les
opérateurs de service public de l'emploi
car ce PJL s'inscrit dans la continuité
d'une politique ambitieuse en matière
d'emploi et de travail en allant en
termes au terme de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage devant laquelle tant
de majorité avait reculé
en menant la réforme des retraites pour
assurer le financement de nos modèles
sociales et favoriser l'emploi des
seniors et en lançant la réforme du
lycée professionnel de la formation et
de l'apprentissage mais aujourd'hui ceux
qui ont le plus besoin d'être
accompagnés sont trop peu suivis quand
ils le sont ils font face à de multiples
acteurs peu coordonner rendant difficile
les démarches en générant des ruptures
dans les parcours les allocataires du
RSA est particulièrement le cas des
allocataires du RSA sont
particulièrement parlant puisque 40%
d'entre eux sont inscrits au Pôle Emploi
seulement le cas des travailleurs en
situation de handicap et tout aussi
urgent le taux de chômage des personnes
en situation de handicap reste près du
double du taux de chômage moyen en 2022
et à ce titre je me réjouis des mesures
d'équité que porte ce texte notamment
pour les personnes handicapées
travaillant dans des esats qui pourront
obtenir les mêmes droits que les
salariés à titre d'exemple 80% des
travailleurs en ESAT non aujourd'hui pas
de mutuelle il faut que le plan de
transformation mise en oeuvre il y a
maintenant trois ans puisse continuer et
que l'État puisse prendre en charge ces
nouvelles dépenses c'est tout le sens de
ce projet de loi quand on parle du droit
au retour c'est en quelque sorte
facilité le passage de l'ESAT à
l'entreprise adaptée ou au milieu
ordinaire et enfin sécuriser le parcours
le retour en carte d'échec car cela peut
arriver dans tous les parcours
professionnels enfin ce texte est aussi
le mérite d'aborder la question de la
garde d'enfants qui est un des
principaux freins à l'accès à l'emploi
notamment pour les femmes nous
connaissons l'engagement des
municipalités en faveur de la petite
enfance il s'agit donc de renforcer et
de conforter les mères dans leur mission
en tant qu'autorité organisatrice pour
garantir un nombre suffisant de place
d'accueil avec un recensement à
l'échelle de la commune et une
trajectoire adaptée la réforme du
service public de la petite enfance va
d'ailleurs dans ce sens avec une
meilleure coordination des différents
acteurs l'objectif est d'ouvrir 100000
places d'accueil d'ici 2027 et 200000
d'ici 2030
et là aussi en termes d'investissement
l'État sera au côté des communes avec
plus d'un,5 milliards en 2027 et plus de
5,7 milliards en 5 ans pour augmenter le
nombre de places en crèche
l'accent sera mis également sur
l'attractivité la formation par l'action
conjointe de l'état des régions des
départements et des branches
professionnelles car sans ces
professionnels il ne peut y avoir
d'accueil de qualité ce service public
c'est la fin du parcours du combattant
des familles c'est un investissement
d'avenir pour la natalité et le
développement des enfants et donc un
levier puissant pour l'emploi finalement
le plein emploi c'est bien sur offrir
davantage aux Français un travail mais
aussi de lutter contre les assignations
sociales et d'offrir une émancipation
c'est permettre l'amélioration des
conditions de travail électivité des
métiers c'est mieux répondre aux
attentes de nos concitoyens sur leur
parcours professionnel en favorisant les
formations les transitions et les
reconversion si les Allemands de ce
texte le Président c'est l'examen de ce
texte en commission a révélé
effectivement des désaccords je pense
que nous partageons collectivement ici
dans cette émission l'objectif du Pôle
emploi et c'est pour ça que le groupe
le temps de parole est un parti pour
tout le monde de manière égale
la parole est à Madame Emilienne
poupirol pour le groupe socialiste pour
4 minutes
le Président Monsieur les ministres même
la rapporteur madame la Présidente de la
Commission mes chers collègues que
l'emmener fut éprouvante pour nos droits
sociaux après la réforme régressive de
l'assurance chômage la réforme brutale
et injuste des retraites nous voici
aujourd'hui à la veille des congélateurs
sociales ce projet de loi dit du plein
emploi le plein d'emploi tel est
l'ambition affichée du gouvernement
certes mais à quel prix celui d'une
précarisation et d'une paupérisation de
notre société ce texte porte une vision
purement adéquationniste de l'emploi
d'un côté les gens qui ne travaillent
pas inscrits obligatoirement maintenant
sur la liste des demandeurs d'emploi et
de l'autre les entreprises qui peintent
à recruter et il suffirait de les mettre
en relation
pour aider sanctionner
pour ceux qui n'obéissent pas à cette
logique pour arriver au plein emploi
cette idée simple pour ne pas dire
simpliste aura pourtant des conséquences
dramatiques pour certains de nos
concitoyens tout d'abord et en préambule
je voudrais vous dire
il y a un point qui me paraît
problématique puisque vous insérez la
réforme d'un droit social le revenu de
solidarité active dans un projet de loi
portant sur le travail et donc du Code
du travail bien loin de la logique
originelle du RMI qui était qui crée un
revenu minimal de subsistance pour
sécuriser les personnes et favoriser une
sortie de la pauvreté le gouvernement
définit le RSA non plus comme un droit
social mais comme mon dispositif de
recherche d'emploi dans la même logique
l'accroissement du conditionnement et
des sanctions pour les bénéficiaires du
RSA semble ici supplanter la volonté
d'accompagnement suspendre le RSA peut
avoir des conséquences dramatiques pour
des personnes dont le quotidien n'est
que survie rappelons et cette mesure ne
fait que stigmatiser un peu plus les
bénéficiaires du RSA le texte porte par
ailleurs également la volonté de
recentraliser la gestion des demandeurs
d'emploi déshabillant de leur
compétences exclusives les régions et
les départements enfin la problématique
du financement durable de ces mesures
doit être soulevée si nous en donnons
l'ambition du gouvernement d'un meilleur
accompagnement la question des moyens
qu'il soit humain ou financiers pour
atteindre cet objectif se pose et les
chiffres présentés par le gouvernement
nous semble bien en deçà des besoins
effectifs
le problème du financement est pourtant
particulièrement important et je crains
que votre dogme néolibéral de réduction
du déficit public en proposant
uniquement une réduction des dépenses
publiques ou des exonérations fiscales
pour les entreprises sans jamais
envisager de recettes nouvelles ne
soient ici source de diminution de
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
de plus nous notons de grands absences
nous avons textes monsieur le ministre
des sujets pourtant primordiaux quand
nous parlons de travail vous prenez en
effet soutenu par la majorité
sénatoriale et la valeur travail
mécanique de la valeur accordée au
travail aux conditions de travail à la
juste rémunération du travail le plein
emploi quoi qu'il en coûte mais quelle
pleine emploi celui des temps partiel
contre la question de la qualité de
l'emploi est parfaitement absente de
votre texte de la même manière la lutte
contre la pauvreté ne semble pas être
une priorité pour ce gouvernement bien
au contraire ce projet de loi n'aboutira
qu'à faire passer des gens de la
précarité à la grande pauvreté absente
également la question du non recours au
droit qui sera aggravé par ce texte et
pourtant le gouvernement avait fait une
priorité pas une ligne non plus sur le
reste à vivre et enfin voici un texte
sur le travail qui ne traite pas des
leviers à la reprise d'activité pour
lever les freins à l'emploi sauf la
petite enfance j'en ai ministre farouche
défenseur des droits sociaux et du
service public de l'emploi de la lutte
contre la pauvreté les membres du groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
porteront donc des propositions pour un
accompagnement plus humain juste et
efficace des personnes sans emploi et
nous voterons contre ce texte qui n'est
en dessous qui ne sait pas cette logique
là pardon merci chers collègues la
parole et maintenant madame Katia pour
ce poly pour le groupe CRCE pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues après la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui a
réduit les droits des allocataires qui a
réduit la durée d'indemnisation de tous
ceux qui perdent leur emploi après la
réforme des retraites qui volent deux
ans aux salariés y compris à ceux et
celles qui travaillent dans des
conditions difficiles après la réforme
des lycées professionnels qui n'est
aucunement guidée par l'intérêt des
élèves vous nous proposez aujourd'hui un
projet de loi intitulé pour le plein
emploi qui ne vise pas et à éradiquer le
chômage dans notre pays mais à atteindre
un taux de chômage inférieur à 5%. le
titre est alléchant le plein emploi j'ai
souscrit nous y souscrivons évidemment
nous sommes favorables à ce que chaque
être humain travaille dans de bonnes
conditions avec un salaire décent votre
projet de loi est en vérité bien loin de
tout ça de plus ce projet aura un impact
conséquent sur la vie de nos concitoyens
et concitoyens et pourtant deux jours à
peine ils seront consacrés
se renoncement à faire disparaître le
chômage dans notre pays consiste à
contraindre les chômeurs à répondre aux
pénuries de main d'oeuvre dans les
métiers en tension en réalité non
seulement il ne suffit pas de traverser
la rue pour trouver un emploi mais le
rapport de France stratégie de mars 2022
consacrée à la prospective des métiers
et des qualifications à 2030 au-delà du
manque de formation
l'inadéquation entre le besoin en
recrutement et la main d'oeuvre
disponible est à mettre en lien avec des
conditions de travail difficiles ou
dégradées l'amélioration des salaires et
des conditions de travail permettrait de
pouvoir de pouvoir les emplois en
tension plutôt que de contraindre les
chômeurs à accepter n'importe quel
emploi parfois pour quelques heures
plutôt que le plein emploi précaire et
sous qualifié nous avons besoin d'un bon
emploi choisi en CDI en et garantissant
un véritable salaire qui permet une vie
digne à chacun la création France
travaille en remplacement de Pôle emploi
va permettre au gouvernement de
privatiser le service public de
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
en intégrant les organismes privés dans
le réseau France travail le ministre du
Travail a déjà annoncé tout son
intention de faire payer la création de
France travail aux assurés sociaux qui
financent l'unique la lettre de cadage
de la future convention de la science
chômage devrait prévoir la fonction des
3 milliards d'euros et la modulation des
allocations selon la conjoncture
économique en durcissant les conditions
de maintien du RSA le gouvernement
choisi de ne pas s'attaquer au non
recours au RSA qui touche 30% des
personnes éligibles la majorité
sénatoriale joue la surenchère avec le
gouvernement sur le contrôle des
chômeurs après les déclarations
d'érections 22 juin dernier selon lequel
il est possible d'aller beaucoup plus
loin dans la réduction des indemnités
chômage qui sont un obstacle dit-il
évident au retour au plein emploi la
commission des affaires sociales a
limité le versement rétroactif du RSA à
trois mensualités
ils ont encore davantage les plus
fragiles les mesures prévues dans le
projet de loi en faveur du handicap vont
dans le bon sens même si elles ne sont
pas suffisantes mais concernant la
stratégie nationale de l'accueil du
jeune enfant celle-ci n'est pas
satisfaisante à 70% l'accueil est
aujourd'hui porté par les maires par les
communes donnez-leur les moyens de
développer l'offre de garde en le
rassurant une pérennité sur le coup de
fonctionnement vous deviez créer
promesse de campagne du président Macron
30 000 places de crèches 4 ans plus tard
8927 places sont créées réfléchissons
vite à un service public de l'enfance
notre groupe porte un projet alternatif
de société qui repose sur la création de
nouveaux droits pour les salariés et
surtout de nouveaux financements pour
financer l'assurance chômage face au
projet de précarité généralisé pour
toutes et tous nous portons un projet de
sécurisation de l'emploi et de la
formation dans l'objectif d'éradication
du chômage et de la précarité ce projet
de l'emploi la sécurité formation
prévoit de former créer des emplois de
qualité sécuriser l'emploi et la
formation en mettant la contribution le
capital et en conditionnant les aides
publiques et créer des instances
démocratiques locales et nationales pour
planifier la priorité à l'emploi au lieu
des profits un système qui assure à
chacun et chacune un emploi une
formation rémunérée pour revenir en
emploi avec une continuité de droit et
de revenus sans passage par la case
chômage face à la case de l'enseignement
professionnel nous portons la
revendication de formation ouverte
adaptée au travail certes mais également
aux travailleurs en formation façon
mesure cosmétiques sur le chant du
handicap nous prenons nous prenons une
réelle prise en compte et un
accompagnement digne y compris des
aidants maintenus dans l'exclusion faute
de statue ce projet est à l'opposé de ce
que nous portons raison pour laquelle
notre groupe votre rencontre ce texte je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Martine Berthet pour
le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur qui s'est absenté un
instant mes chers collègues le texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui porte une
ambition majeure il entend réorganiser
le service public de l'emploi à tous les
échelons territoriaux et améliorer
l'accueil et l'accompagnement des
personnes en recherche d'un travail
l'enjeu est de taille car nous sommes
encore loin du plein emploi notre pays
compte près de 3 millions de chômeurs
13% de notre jeunesse et non seulement
sans emploi mais ne suit aucune
formation ni parcours d'études
ce sont autant d'opportunités manquées
d'insertion professionnelle et sociale
d'accomplissement personnel et
d'accroissement des revenus
mais je souhaiterais insister dans mon
propos sur l'enjeu que représente
l'amélioration du service public de
l'emploi pour nos entreprises faisant
écho ou récent rapports que j'ai
présenté avec mes collègues Michel
Canevet et Florence blatrix compta
intitulé formé pour aujourd'hui et pour
demain les compétences en jeu de
croissance et de société il a été adopté
à l'unanimité par la Délégation aux
entreprises en 2022 pour les entreprises
les tensions de recrutement et la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre ont atteint de
nouveaux sommets ce sont désormais plus
de 2 sur 3 qui sont confrontés le taux
de vacances des emplois et 5 fois
supérieur à son taux de croisière en
comparaison avec les pays européens qui
nous entourent nos entreprises ont plus
de difficultés à pouvoir leurs emplois
malgré un taux de chômage plus élevé en
cela le service public de l'emploi a un
rôle très important à jouer pour faire
se rencontrer l'offre et la demande
d'emploi
je rappelle que la loi confie
explicitement à Pôle emploi la mission
d'accompagner les entreprises dans leur
recrutement pourtant la majorité des
entreprises à quelques rares exceptions
géographiques près estiment toujours que
son appui est insuffisante surtout pour
les petites entreprises je suis heureuse
que la commission des affaires sociales
est adoptée un amendement visant à
réaffirmer et renforcer la mission
d'accompagnement de Pôle Emploi
vis-à-vis des entreprises et surtout la
réponse à leurs besoins j'en profite
pour féliciter notre collègue madame la
Présidente Pascal grunier rapporteur
pour son remarquable travail ainsi que
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales Catherine de roche
avec le président de la Délégation aux
entreprises nous proposerons d'aller
plus loin dans cet accompagnement par un
amendement visant à instaurer dans
chaque territoire un guichet PME au sein
du réseau France travail qui servira
d'interlocuteurs unique pour le dialogue
et le suivi des PME c'est cette logique
qui fait le succès par exemple de la
team France Export auprès des PME et il
nous semble utile de l'appliquer pour
France travail
l'un des défis auxquels devra répondre
la réforme et celui des métiers en
tension parmi lesquels figurent de
nombreux métiers essentiels à la vie de
la nation 120 métiers sont aujourd'hui
en tension contre environ 50 en 2015 si
le gouvernement a déjà fait un pas en ce
sens avec la constitution de Viviers
pour certains métiers il faut passer à
l'échelle supérieure et couvrir
davantage de besoins aussi nous vous
proposons d'inclure systématiquement
dans l'accompagnement des demandeurs
d'emploi une sensibilisation aux métiers
en tension du territoire pour mieux
informer et déconstruire les préjugés
par ailleurs nous soutenons la position
de Madame la rapporteur visant à assurer
une participation de l'ensemble des
acteurs locaux de l'insertion et de
l'emploi au réseau France travail ils
sont des maillons essentiels de
l'accompagnement du dernier kilomètre et
sont extrêmement agiles pour combler les
trous dans la raquette de l'approche de
masse de Pôle emploi
la Commission a aussi introduit une plus
grande coopération entre service public
de l'emploi et services publics de
l'éducation effectivement le dialogue
entre école et entreprise mais aussi
entre système éducatif et services
publics de l'emploi nous paraît
fondamental pour une orientation choisie
et informée de nos jeunes dans la même
attention nous présenterons un
amendement qui vise à prévoir un suivi
renforcé des jeunes diplômés de lycées
professionnels par Pôle Emploi l'année
de leur diplôme et pour les deux années
à suivre moins de la moitié des diplômés
de cap sont insérés dans l'emploi deux
ans après leur diplôme il faut inverser
la tendance et mieux prévenir le
décrochage
enfin alors que ce texte acte le
lancement d'un second plan
d'investissement des compétences prenant
garde à ne pas ponctionner les
ressources dédiées à la formation
professionnelle et à la formation des
salariés au profit de la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi entre 2019 et 2022
plus de 6,4 milliards d'euros ont ainsi
été prélevés sur les ressources de
France compétences au profit du pic
alors qu'elles sont normalement dédiées
au financement de l'apprentissage à
l'action des OPCO ou encore des plans de
développement des compétences élaborées
par les entreprises nous porterons donc
un amendement visant à plafonner le
prélèvement annuel effectué sur les
ressources de France compétences au
profit du pic je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant Madame Corinne
Ferret pour le groupe socialiste pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame la rapporteur nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour débattre
du projet de loi planemploi et si le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain partagent l'ambition
d'atteindre cet objectif nous n'avons de
toute évidence pas la même vision de ce
que recouvre cette notion le plein
emploi devant être ici obtenu à tout
prix envers et contre tout une vision
bientôt brutale et stigmatisante en 1988
lorsque la gauche a fait adopter à
l'unanimité la création du RMI
aujourd'hui du RSA l'important était
qu'un moyen de vivre ou plutôt de
survivre soit garantie à tous en même
temps qu'un droit à l'insertion sociale
et professionnelle avec ce texte le
gouvernement introduit un changement de
philosophie du RSA instaure un
déséquilibre entre droit et devoirs et
ajoute de la sécurité à des personnes
déjà très fragilisées
avant on considérait que la société
avait le devoir d'insérer et
d'accompagner les allocataires
aujourd'hui c'est l'inverse ce sont les
allocataires qui ont des devoirs des
obligations déjà plus de 30% des
Français ayant droit au RSA ne le
demande pas alors qu'il aurait fallu des
propositions pour lutter contre ce non
recours il n'y a rien ou plutôt si de la
conditionnalité et des nouvelles
sanctions qui risquent d'aggraver encore
la précarité des plus fragiles oui ce
texte est injuste envers les demandeurs
d'emploi et représente une vraie
violence sociale il est tout autant flou
et recentralisateur ce texte est flou en
ce qui évite soigneusement de parler des
moyens et renvoie à des décrets dont on
ne sait rien la mise en oeuvre de
nombreux de nombre de dispositions où
sont les milliards qui permettraient de
mettre en place l'accompagnement
intensif et personnalisé promis et
d'accéder à un emploi durable dans la
même lignée ce texte est
recentralisateur la compétence exclusive
des régions sur la formation
professionnelle des demandeurs fois
issus de 40 ans de décentralisation
devient une compétence partagée est en
région la région se réduira demain à un
rôle d'opérateur de l'État comment les
représentants des territoires et des
collectivités que nous sommes
peuvent-ils accepter cela alors même que
notre assemblée vient de rendre via le
groupe de travail sur la
décentralisation lancée par le président
du Sénat en octobre dernier 15 nouvelles
propositions pour redonner aux élus
locaux leur pouvoir d'agir les
collectivités leurs élus attendent de
nous une décentralisation claire et des
transferts de compétences effectifs la
régionalisation des compétences de
l'emploi et la formation professionnelle
est un modèle efficient et conforme à
celui de la plupart des autres pays
européens pourquoi la remettre en
question nous nous inquiétons
particulièrement pour notre jeunesse
également jusqu'ici suivi par l'émission
locale elles aussi mis à mal certes ces
dernières jouent un rôle décisif dans
l'accès à l'emploi des jeunes mais pas
que l'ensemble des rencontrer par
l'émission locale ne correspondent pas à
la définition d'une demandeur d'emploi
et il ne faudrait pas que la logique par
trop administrative du projet de loi
s'avère contre-productive dans la
relation d'accompagnement et pour
l'accès au droit nous veillerons donc
par voie d'amendement à ce que l'on
préserve ce véritable service public
territorialisé de l'insertion des jeunes
dont la toux est d'avoir une approche
globale de l'accompagnement vous l'avez
compris nous sommes opposés à ce texte
qui veut remettre chacun au travail à
mars à marche forcée en augmentant
encore un peu plus la pression et les
menaces sur les personnes sans emploi
nous n'acceptons pas que les petites
phrases qui consistent à faire penser
qu'il suffit de traverser la rue ou même
de faire le tour du vieux port pour
trouver un emploi ce sont donc avec ces
provocations pour nous il est important
que l'individu s'inscrit dans une
logique d'insertion professionnelle
durable en termes de motivation de
projet de salaire et qu'il
n'addique pas ses aspirations
professionnelles personnel le travail
est un facteur d'intégration et
d'émancipation s'il est librement choisi
et s'il s'exerce dans des conditions
décentes se faisant un véritable service
public de l'emploi ne serait forcé les
personnes à occuper des emplois
précaires et sous-payés il doit au
contraire organiser un droit à l'emploi
de qualité pour tous c'est cette vision
que nous défendrons lors des débats ces
prochains jours je conclurai en
rappelant que le gouvernement nous avait
également promis une loi petite enfance
afin de mieux répondre aux besoins des
familles et de donner à chaque enfant
les mêmes chances or le compte n'est pas
avec l'article 10 du projet de loin une
sorte de cavalier législatif loin de
créer un véritable service public global
de la petite enfance et qui interroge
pour le moins en termes de faisabilité
au regard des pénuries de personnels et
des charges qui incombent déjà aux
collectivités je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant au dernier orateur inscrit
Monsieur Bruno Belin pour le groupe les
républicains pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur
plein emploi deux mots dont la France
rêve depuis 50 ans alors écoutez les
précédents orateurs monsieur le ministre
l'évaluation de la copie pourrait être
ministre sympathique compatible méritant
ces dernières semaines le montrer
en ville louable mais copier incomplètes
superficielles voire à contre sens de
l'histoire alors à contre sens de
l'histoire parce que on a bien compris
que certaines collectivités étaient
vigilantes les régions les départements
aussi parce que Myo responsabilités donc
soit face à leurs compétences
historiques soit parce que les questions
de moyens vont vite se poser en ville
loi on l'a bien compris mais évidemment
les grandes questions et beaucoup de
questions sur ce texte sont quel
gouvernance quels moyens quelle
stratégie alors sur les questions sont
surtout les flous il y en a eu et
notamment en premier lieu cette question
de RSA
contrat d'accompagnement la présidente
grunie de la soulever il y a eu un petit
manque de dommage parce que vous n'avez
pas annoncé finalement la couleur sur
les contours de ce Contrat
d'Accompagnement puis j'aurais un moment
donné le dire tordre le coup à une idée
préconçue que finalement les
bénéficiaires du RSA constituent un
vivier de réticent à l'embauche
réfractaire à l'emploi ou complaisant à
l'inactivité
loin s'en fout je connais l'énergie que
mettent les directions des conseils
départementaux à trouver des solutions
pour le retour à l'emploi des
bénéficiaires du RSA mais demain matin
quels moyens allez vous allouer au
Conseil départementaux quand il faudrait
inscrire 100% des bénéficiaires du RSA
France travail alors qu'aujourd'hui à
peine 40% sont inscrits à Pôle emploi il
y a la question des RQTH et des
travailleurs handicapés le ceinture
mouillés l'a évoqué à a juste titre
parce que demain matin par exemple un
bénéficiaire de la hache avec une RQTH
perdrait-il une partie de ces
allocations de ses revenus s'il trouver
un travail la question des actes
vous-même monsieur le ministre évoqué la
question des esats or vous savez comme
moi qui ne manque de place en France
donc ça fait partie des sujets qu'il
faut aborder dans cette dans une grande
loi travail et puis le ministre comme je
vous ai pas oublié la question des
responsabilités sur la compétence en
France parce que ça a été dit par tous
les orateurs c'est un frein pour
reprendre l'expression commune employée
sur la garde d'enfants mais c'est
toujours là on en revient à la question
des moyens vous même annoncer tout à
l'heure 6 milliards au regard des 35800
communes et 4000 intercommunalités qui
pourraient en responsabilité sur ce
sujet ça fait que quelques milliers
d'euros environ 15000 par collectivité
vous en conviendrez que c'est bien
insuffisant dans le contexte financier
budgétaire que connaissent les
collectivités depuis quelques années
alors
cette question du plein emploi c'est
évidemment comment on arrive à à
diminuer le nombre le nombre d'offres
non pourvu on retrouve les quatre sujets
d'abord l'accompagnement et là c'est la
question des missions locales que
fait-on comment et dans quel cadre on
reprend la question aussi de la
formation quelle est la bonne voie de
départ et là il faudra un jour qu'on est
le débat sur parcoursup parce que on
parle des métiers en tension lesquels
mais comment il va-t-on et dans quel
délai et puis à la question du logement
et je pense notamment au débat des
saisonniers il y a la question bien sûr
de la mobilité je ne pensais pour les
associations qui insère les travailleurs
grâce à des efforts de mobilité mais qui
n'ont pas de moyens pas de moyens de
l'État je pense à dynamom dans le
département où je suis lu où il n'y a
aucun moyen alors cette loi pleine
emploi évidemment
c'est un petit pas
que on votera un certain nombre mais
pour le bon que géant il faudrait un peu
plus de moyens et un peu plus d'ambition
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
et le ministre de la parole
les deux
mes premiers monsieur le Président nous
serons nous serons bref
simplement monsieur le Président pour
remercier les différents orateurs de sa
discussion générale les amendements vont
nous permettre de revenir sur chacun des
points je voudrais simplement apporter
des précisions sur sur trois points le
premier concerne la question des
activités effectivement dans le projet
de loi tel que transmis au Parlement
nous avions indiqué dans l'article
concernant le contrat d'engagement
réciproque que l'intensité de celui-ci
devait être définie par l'organisme
référent les allocataires en tenant
compte de l'âge du niveau de
qualification de la situation économique
et sociale du bassin d'emploi des freins
à l'axe à l'emploi en termes de mobilité
de garde d'enfants ou de santé et en
prévoyant donc l'intensité soit définie
dans le cadre du contrat notre objectif
est évidemment d'avoir le plus souvent
possible c'est 15 amateurs d'activité
j'ai vu et bien sûr j'entends la demande
de la commission des affaires sociales
d'être plus précis et plus offensive sur
ce point avec cette inscription dans la
loi par un va te demander en commission
minimum de 15 heures je pense que nous
aurons le débat que nous devons penser
aussi qu'un certain nombre
d'allocataires sont extrêmement éloignés
de l'emploi et parfois extrêmement
abîmée par des incidents de vie et que
dans un premier temps un premier niveau
d'activité peut-être un niveau
intermédiaire plus progressif c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que nous avons
renvoyé à l'article 6 vont prélever
l'article 6 la possibilité que celle des
ceux qui sont les plus éloignés face
l'objet uniquement d'un suivi social et
que tous les 6 à 12 mois un bilan soit
fait pour voir quelle possibilité nous
aurions de les accompagner sur un suivi
professionnel et donc une insertion
professionnelle le deuxième point que je
voulais clarifier concerne les missions
locales je les dis dans mon propos
liminaire il n'y a pas de changement de
statut il n'y a pas de mise en cause de
l'autonomie des missions locales elles
sont opérateurs spécialisées et acteurs
central pour l'accueil des jeunes et
nous avons eu des discussions avec
l'Union nationale des missions locales
qui s'inquiétait que dans une version de
l'avant-projet apparaissent l'exercice
de leurs compétences d'accueil de tous
les jeunes par délégation de France
travail et cette notion de part
délégation tu as été supprimé du projet
qui vous a transmis ce qui indique
combien elles sont respectées dans leur
statut deux éléments de précision le
commencement du pour le financement des
missions locales reste avec l'État tout
comme d'ailleurs pour les structures
d'insertion par l'activité économique
l'opérateur Pôle Emploi aujourd'hui
France travaille demain n'aura pas cette
compétence de conversion de convention
financière et donc il n'y aura pas de
lien de subordination par le financement
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose et que l'émission locale seront
amenées et ça c'est une nouveauté à
participer au comité local France
travail et donc à participer à la
définition des orientations de la
politique de l'emploi à l'échelle des
territoires ce qui est une prérogative
supplémentaire la question des moyens a
été posée c'est le troisième point que
je vais évoquer évidemment ce texte
n'est pas un texte financier les moyens
devront passer par deux canaux le
premier canal concerne le projet de loi
de financement dans la mesure où nous
nous sommes engagés à accompagner les
départements dans la mise en place d'un
accompagnement renforcé nous sommes
évidemment dans cette période en
discussion et en préparation du PLF 2024
avec une logique de déploiement
progressif puisque vous avez vu que le
projet de loi généralise
l'accompagnement renforcé pour 2025 je
précise qu'il est généralise mais ça ne
veut pas dire 100% d'accompagnement
intensif puisque nous savons par exemple
que 32% des allocataires du RSA sont des
foyers monoparentaux pour l'essentiel
des femmes avec des enfants et donc des
difficultés de garde et ça représente un
frein suffisamment majeur pour que la
progressivité de la mise en oeuvre du
nouveau système soit une forme
d'évidence le deuxième canal concerne
effectivement la convention qui existe
aujourd'hui convention tripartite entre
l'État Pôle emploi et du nédy qui
prévoit que ludique affecte 11% ses
recettes à au fonctionnement de Pôle
emploi c'est ce que j'appelle une
dépense active puisque effectivement il
s'agit d'argent des cotisations qui
financent un service public de l'emploi
mais si le service public de l'emploi
améliore l'accès à la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi améliore le retour à
l'emploi des demandeurs d'emploi c'est
une dépense active qui permettra d'avoir
plus d'emplois plus de cotisations et
moins de dépenses d'allocation et en
cela c'est vertueux un dernier point
pour dire monsieur le président que
avant que mon collègue Jean-Christophe
comme reviennent sur d'autres sujets que
concernant l'intervention de Monsieur
mouillé sur la question du modèle
économiques des esats nous avons
effectivement et je pense indépendamment
même de ce texte de loi amener une
réflexion sur le modèle économique de
ceci les tensions de recrutement connues
sur le marché du travail qui a rappelé
madame Berthet notamment ont amené les
entreprises à se tourner vers des
recrues et des nouvelles de nouveaux de
nouveaux employés qui sont par
définition les plus employables de ceux
qui restaient aujourd'hui sans emploi
donc il y a un vrai modèle une vraie
réflexion à avoir qui plus est dans une
logique de convergence de convergence
des droits et donc d'impact financier
sur les esats et pour répondre aussi
votre question sur la H2 et le
plafonnement du temps de travail nous y
travaillons avec Jean-Christophe combe
pour par décret des plafonnés le temps
de travail ouvert ou titulaire aux
bénéficiaires d'une H2 qui souhaite
travailler plus et qui ne serait plus
cantonné au 17h30 que vous avez évoqué
mais c'est strictement réglementaire le
président de la République s'y engagé en
sortie de CNH pour le reste je
reviendrai sur les différents points à
l'occasion des amendements sachant mais
madame la rapporteur le sait que pour au
moins les deux tiers sinon les trois
quarts des amendements adoptés en
commission le gouvernement ne proposera
aucune remise en question considérant
que beaucoup d'entre eux ont permis
d'améliorer d'enrichir le texte
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs trois points
très rapides pour conclure cette
discussion générale le premier c'est de
vous dire que je me réjouis vraiment
sincèrement de l'inscription aussi
rapide dans un texte des engagements
pris à l'occasion de la conférence
actuelle du handicap pour ce qui
concerne l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap et le beau symbole
aujourd'hui que nous portions ensemble
avec le ministre du Travail ces mesures
ça montre que on passe aujourd'hui dans
une vision d'accès aux droits
fondamentaux pour les personnes en
situation du handicap et vers le droit
et le milieu ordinaire le second point
c'est que je me réjouis que vous ayez
tous
appuyé beaucoup d'intérêt pour la
politique d'accueil du jeune enfant j'ai
entendu aussi vos diverses inquiétudes
et on y reviendra à l'occasion de
la discussion qu'on aura sur l'article
10 mais je voudrais vous rassurer comme
j'ai essayé de le faire en anticipation
pour pouvoir porter conseil politique
importante pour l'emploi pour la lutte
contre les inégalités de destin pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et pour la natalité dans notre pays on
dire que les moyens ils sont là ils sont
exceptionnels c'est inédit j'ai signé ce
matin encore une fois la convention
d'objectifs et de gestion de la CNAF
tous les acteurs présents étaient ravis
et reconnaissent l'investissement
considérable de l'État sur sur cette
politique publique donc les moyens ils
sont là je veillerai à ce que de façon
très effective et on travaillera
ensemble aussi avec les collectivités et
la branche famille pour les mettre en
oeuvre qu'il réponde aux préoccupations
en particulier des maires on a bien
entendu encore une fois leur crainte
quand aux modalités de financement moins
sur l'investissement et plus sur le
fonctionnement il y aura un vrai
rééquilibrage pour favoriser la création
de de place pour favoriser aussi bien de
les aider la gestion de ces de ces
services publics et je prendrai là aussi
des engagements sur les compensations
vis-à-vis des vis-à-vis des
collectivités et puis et puis pouvoir
les accompagner aussi pour améliorer
l'attractivité des métiers je pense que
c'est notre plus grand défi demain pour
pouvoir déployer les places d'accueil
dans notre pays et puis dernier point
très rapide il n'y a pas effectivement
directement dans ce projet de loi de
mesure en lien avec la lutte contre la
pauvreté je redis simplement que le
choix que nous faisons et je le porte
depuis très longtemps y compris dans mes
engagements précédents la meilleure des
politiques sociales c'est l'emploi c'est
de permettre un accès à l'emploi des
personnes qui en sont éloignées et il
n'y a pas de doute là-dessus on
présentera prochainement avec la
première ministre un pacte des
solidarités qui prendra le relais de la
stratégie de lutte contre la pauvreté
que nous avons travaillé avec l'ensemble
des acteurs de la solidarité les
associations les caisses de sécurité
sociale les les élus pour pouvoir
là aussi continuer à lutter de façon
importante contre la pauvreté il y a
quatre axes je vais pas tout décrire
mais la question de France travail et
l'insertion par l'emploi et un axe
majeur de de ce plan et on y travaillera
en particulier pour aller chercher les
personnes qui sont les plus éloignées et
puis vous avez sans doute vu concernant
la question de l'accès au droit que j'en
ai fait aussi une priorité la lutte
contre de la lutte contre le non recours
j'ai installé la semaine dernière le
comité de coordination de l'accès aux
droits lancé officiellement avec le
choix des territoires à
l'expérimentation territoire zéro non
recours on a 39 aujourd'hui bassin de
vie qui se sont engagés des actes pour
lutter contre le non recours donc
le gouvernement agit et fait beaucoup
dans la lutte contre la pauvreté pour
l'accès aux droits fondamentaux de
chacun de nos citoyens et pour un accès
à cette politique sociale volontariste
je vous remercie
très bien nous allons attaquer enfin les
articles à l'intitulé du titre premier
j'ai un amendement 389 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors le
titre premier l'article 2 introduisent
le contrat d'engagement actuellement
existe le contrat d'engagement
réciproque qui même si seulement 50% des
bénéficiaires du RSA orienté vers ce
type de parcours en dispose
effectivement et censé constituer l'un
des dispositifs centraux de
l'accompagnement des allocataires du RSA
la suppression du qualificatif